Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle hier zu einer weiteren Ausgabe von Raumzeit.
Und wie schon in den letzten Sendungen sich abgezeichnet hat,
heute geht's wieder um das ZERN.
Ich bin hier in Genf vor Ort und spreche mit einer ganzen Reihe von Gesprächspartnern.
Und so auch in dieser Sendung. Und heute geht es um die Detektoren,
die es ja hier so einige gibt, an dem großen Large Hadron Collider,
dem großen Beschleunigerring, der hier aufgebaut worden ist in den letzten Jahrzehnten
und fleißig betrieben wird und wie man ja auch schon gehört hat zu diversen
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen geführt hat.
Und diese Erkenntnisse gäbe es nicht, würde nicht das, was da beschleunigt wird,
auch mal ausgelesen werden.
Es muss ja auch was kollidieren, wenn man diese Kollision auswerten will.
Und eine dieser Kollisionsmaschinen, dieser Detektoren heißt ALICE,
Large Ion Collider Experiment und darüber spreche ich heute mit Kai Schweda.
Hallo, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit.
Hallo Tim, gut dich zu sehen.
Ja, Kai du bist, stimmt das, Alice Deputy Spokesperson steht hier.
Genau, seit Januar diesen Jahres für drei Jahre. Spokesperson wird demokratisch
gewählt von den teilnehmenden Instituten und alle drei Jahre gibt es einen neuen
Spokesperson. Und der ist auch nicht wiederwählbar, das heißt nach drei Jahren ist es vorbei.
Aha, warum macht man das?
Generell ist es am Zehren so, dass auch die Generaldirektorin,
die wir jetzt haben, von den Mitgliedstaaten gewählt wird.
Das macht man, dass Machtstrukturen nicht verkrusten. Wir haben ja gesehen,
wenn eine Kanzlei in Deutschland vier Legislaturperioden überlebt...
Da haben die Leute die Schnauze voll. Und genau das ist das Ziel vom CERN.
Selbst die Sekretärinnen in den Sekretariaten wechseln alle 5 oder 6 Jahre die Abteilung auch um,
natürlich auch wenn man eine bestimmte Aufgabe eine Zeit macht,
wird es sehr routinemäßig, dann sehen die andere Abteilungen und das wird sehr
aktiv betrieben beim CERN.
Es gibt ja auch genug, wo man durchrotieren kann. Also es bleibt abwechslungsreich.
Und ich denke das schärft dann auch den Blick für das Ganze dann doch auch,
dass man sieht, aha andere Abteilungen machen auch cooles Zeug und haben aber
vielleicht einen anderen Stil und dann übertragen sich natürlich auch Erfahrungen.
Aber das heißt, dass man nicht mehr so viel Wissenschaft macht oder?
Wenn man Spokesperson ist oder ist das nur so ein Anhängsel?
Nach wie vor zwei Doktoranden, die ich betreue, die unsere Daten auswerten und
Physikanalyse betreiben und die auch veröffentlichen die Ergebnisse.
Also es ist eigentlich nur so ein zusätzlicher Job und kein neuer.
Also ich denke Spokesperson, das ist ja der CEO wäre das, bei einer großen Aktiengesellschaft
oder im deutschen Sprachraum ist das der Vorstandsvorsitzende.
Ich bin der Stellvertreter.
Und ich behalte noch mehr 10% meiner Zeit für Dinge, die mir Spaß machen,
zum Beispiel Doktorandbetreuung, ich mache noch Lehre in der Uni Heidelberg
in der Physik und das will ich nicht aufgeben. Als Brooks-Person wird es vielleicht anders.
Wie hat es dann angefangen mit der Wissenschaft?
Ich denke schon in der Schule, so rückblickend waren immer die Naturwissenschaften
das, was mich interessiert hat und dann im Studium war es die Kernphysik.
Alles andere hat mich dann weniger interessiert.
Warum?
Das kann ich nicht sagen. Vielleicht ist das Purismus,
dass man die Kern- und Teilchenphysik versucht ja die Natur zu beschreiben,
indem man die Kräfte auf fundamentale Teilchen und fundamentale Wechselwirkungen
reduziert und vielleicht ist es dieser Reduktionismus, den ich so attraktiv finde.
Ja und auch natürlich dieser Teilchen Zoo, das hatten wir ja schon im Eingangsgespräch,
Standardmodell, das ist einfach so das, was alles definiert.
Von daher glaube ich auch nochmal besonders interessant sein kann.
Da gibt es unterschiedliche Meinungen, wir versuchen das,
wie gesagt, über fundamentale Teilchen- und Wechselwirkungen zu beschreiben,
aber selbst wenn man diese Wechselwirkungen nicht beliebig genau kennt,
könnte niemand ausrechnen, welche Formation eine Schneeflocke wenn man also
Systeme hat, die aus sehr vielen Teilchen bestehen.
Prinzipiell kann man das machen, es gelingt aber keinem, weil dann gibt es eben
kollektive Phänomene, die nicht immer aus den fundamentalen Wechselwirkungen kommen.
Oder anders ausgedrückt, Europa braucht unbedingt ein Schneeflockenformungsforschungszentrum.
Nein, ich will das nicht ins Lächerliche ziehen, aber es gibt auch emergente
Phänomene, auch ALICE beschäftigt sich damit, vielleicht kommen wir da noch
später drauf, die man eben nicht so einfach aus den fundamentalen Wechselwirkungen herleiten kann.
Alles nicht so einfach. Trotz alledem gibt es den Bedarf hier mal ins Detail zu gehen.
Ja, Alice. Also ich habe es schon gesagt, Large Ion Collider Experiment mit
den Abkürzungen ist ja immer so eine Sache. Man will immer auf irgendwas hinaus.
Eine schöne Abkürzung, liest sich halt gut.
Aber es beschreibt ja schon auch in etwa was getan wird. Wovon reden wir jetzt?
Wir haben hier am Standort den großen Ring, den Archidron Collider,
den Beschleunigerring, der halt die Teilchen ordentlich auf Fahrt bringt.
Und entlang dieses Rings gibt es verschiedenste Instrumente,
wie man sagt, wobei das Wort irgendwie nicht so richtig erfasst,
um was für Kolosse es sich dabei handelt.
Sehr sehr große, sehr komplexe technische Geräte, die dann eben diese beschleunigten
Teilchen kollidieren lässt und sie dabei beobachtet.
Also ein Detektor. ALICE ist jetzt einer dieser Detektoren, die alle mehr oder
weniger, also die sozusagen alle parallel und unabhängig voneinander entwickelt wurden.
Das heißt hinter jedem dieser Detektoren steckt eine eine Philosophie,
eine Technik Wissenschaftsphilosophie, wie man auf dieses beschleunigte Teilchen schaut.
Also wir schauen nicht auf das beschleunigte Teilchen, sondern auf das kollidierende.
Die beiden Teilchen kriegen sehr viel Energie mit. Das ist Bewegungsenergie.
Und die kollidieren und dann wird in dieser Kollision ein Großteil dieser Energie,
die ich vorher reinstecke mit dem Collider, mit dem Beschleuniger,
die wird frei und erzeugt neue Teilchen. Da entstehen in der Kollision neue
Teilchen und diese neuen Teilchen, die untersuchen wir.
Und was ist jetzt sozusagen die Philosophie gewesen beim Design von ALICE?
Anfang der 1990er Jahre hat das CERN ernsthaft überlegt und auch eine Designstudie
zum Large Hadron Collider entwickelt.
Das heißt, sie haben sich überlegt, welche Energie brauchen wir,
um in der Teilchenphysik Fortschritt zu machen. Es ging damals um das Higgs-Boson,
das auch vor zehn Jahren entdeckt wurde.
Und dann war klar, da gab es dann die Teilchenphysik-Gemeinschaft,
die Community, baut traditionell zwei Detektoren mit unterschiedlicher Technologie,
um eben diesen Nachweis des Higgs-Teilchens einwandfrei festlegen zu können.
Weil wenn man das gleiche sieht oder dieselben Schlüsse zieht aus zwei vollständig
unterschiedlichen Beobachtungen, dann kann man auch sicher sein, dass es stimmt.
Genau, so ist das traditionell in der Teilchenphysik, auch bei anderen Kollidern wurde,
als das Topquark entdeckt wurde, waren es auch zwei große Experimente und dann
war klar am Large Hadron Collider, dieser Ring, die ja 100 Meter unter der Erde
ist, der 27 Kilometer lang ist, hat vier Kollisionszonen.
Da war vorher ein anderer Kollider drin, der Elektronen und Positronen kollidiert
hat. Und da gibt es vier Wechselwirkungspunkte, wo die Strahlen kollidieren.
Es gab also noch zwei weitere.
Kollisionspunkte, wo man ein Experiment aufstellen kann und dann hat sich unser Feld,
das noch recht jung ist, die schweren Physik überlegt, wir könnten da bei diesen
höchsten zugänglichen Kollisionsenergien einen Detektor bauen und der ist nicht
für Proton-Proton-Kollisionen zuständig,
denn in Proton-Proton-Kollisionen wurde das Higgs-Boson entdeckt und wird weiter
erforscht, welche Eigenschaften es hat, Sondern man kann auch einen Monat pro
Jahr, also eine relativ kurze Zeit, schwere Bleikerne reinsetzen und die beschleunigen.
Und das ist das zentrale Thema von ALICE.
Was ist jetzt so besonders an diesen schweren Teilen?
Die Frage ist, was passiert, wenn ich sehr viel Energie in ein Volumen pumpe,
das sehr viel größer ist als ein Proton.
Darüber ist noch wenig bekannt. was passiert mit dem Vakuum,
wenn ich da sehr viel, sehr sehr viel Energie reinstecke, über ein sehr großes
Volumen, groß, wie gesagt, groß im Vergleich zu der Größe eines Protons.
Und dann kommen da eben bei einer Proton-Proton-Kollision kommen ein paar hundert
Teilchen raus, die erzeugt werden.
Bei einer Blei-Blei-Kollision, da habe ich ja, Blei hat 82 Protonen und diese
Bleikerne sind völlig nackt. Wir nehmen denen alle Elektronen weg,
dass man sie möglichst stark beschleunigen kann. Das heißt, dieser Bleikern
ist 82 Plus geladen, der hat die Ladung von 82 Protonen.
Und dann kommen noch 126 Neutronen dazu. dann habe ich also 208.
Nukleon, also 208 Protonen plus Neutronen, habe ich ein sehr großes System,
das kollidiert und da entstehen 20.000 geladene Teilchen, nicht nur ein paar
hundert. Und das ist der große Unterschied zu ALICE.
Wir müssen bei einer einzigen Kollision eine sehr, sehr hohe Teilchenzahldichte
untersuchen können und dafür haben wir einen speziellen Detektor gebaut.
Also die Überlegung, was für einen Detektor wir gebaut haben,
kommt daraus, was passiert in dieser Kollision.
Und es war sehr schnell klar, wenn man am Large Hadron Collider ein Schwerion-Experiment,
in dem man Bleikerne kollidiert, bauen möchte, braucht man zunächst mal praktisch
die gesamte Physikergemeinschaft, die sich mit so einer Physik beschäftigt.
Weil man einfach einen Detektor, weil die Herausforderungen so groß sind auf
der Detektorseite, auf der Datenaufnahmeseite vom Rechenanspruch,
dass man da praktisch fast alle Physiker, die in dem Feld arbeiten, zusammenbringen muss.
Und dann war auch sehr schnell klar, da muss dieser Detektor nicht nur eine
Teilmessung machen oder ein ganz besonderes Signal und eine Sonde untersuchen
können, sondern sehr breit aufgestellt sein, dass er möglichst alle Signale erkennen kann.
Warum nimmt man Blei? Also es gibt ja sicherlich auch noch schwerere,
man kann ja auch Uran nehmen.
Ja genau, Uran wurde auch gemacht, nicht Amzern. Dazu braucht man eine bestimmte Quelle.
Quelle. Man fängt ja an ein Teilchen zu beschleunigen, in dem es immer zum Beispiel
im Proton nimmt man das Elektron weg, dann ist es positiv geladen,
dann lege ich ein elektrisches Feld an und im elektrischen Feld bewegt sich
eine positive Ladung entlang der Feldlinie und wird beschleunigt.
Und Blei ist möglichst schwer, Uran ist noch schwerer.
Aber für Uran muss man eine spezielle Quelle haben, das hat das CERN nicht,
das wurde aber in anderen Experimenten gemacht. Da braucht man eine ganz spezielle
Quelle. Das ist also ein technologisches Argument.
Also Quelle im Sinne von, also nicht wo man das Uran her bekäme,
sondern wie man das sozusagen erstmal in den Ring überhaupt reinschweißt.
Wie man das vorbeschleunigt.
Die Frage ist immer, wie fange ich an? Ich habe zuerst ein neutrales Atom,
ein Bleiatom oder ein Bleikern.
Und da muss ich erst mal den positiv oder auch negativ laden.
Ich gebe ihm ein Elektron dazu und ich nehme eins weg aus der Atomhülle und
dann fange ich an, das zu beschleunigen.
Und das ist die Schwierigkeit bei Uran. Wir hatten auch sehr gerne Uran-Kollisionen.
Okay, also bleiht sozusagen der Kompromiss aus. Da weiß man,
wie man es hinkriegt und es ist schwer genug, dass es einen Unterschied macht.
Ganz genau, aber der LHC hat auch mittelschwere Kerne schon kollidiert, Xenonkerne.
Das hat wunderbar funktioniert. Da hatten wir mal sechs Stunden Strahl mit Xenonkerne.
Und warum ist jetzt sozusagen, also das habe ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden,
also klar Protonen aufeinander ballern, das bringt einen schon mal weit und
hat auch irgendwie das Higgs-Feld nachweisen können.
Was ist jetzt sozusagen die Erwartungshaltung gewesen, wenn man sagt,
okay, es ist besser, wenn man
jetzt viele Protonen hat, weil man dann mehr sieht oder was anderes sieht?
Weil man genau neue Eigenschaften sieht. Man sieht dann plötzlich,
das muss ich weiter ausholen, die Protonen sind ja keine fundamentalen Teilchen.
Elektron ist ein Elementarteilchen, das hat eine Ladung, das hat eine bestimmte
Masse, aber Protonen sind ja ausgedehnt,
die bestehen selbst noch mal aus Elementarteilchen, das sind die Quarks.
Und das ist eben das fundamentale Teil, die Quarks sind Bestand der Bis dahin.
Des Standardsmodells der Teilchenphysik und da gibt es sechs verschiedene Quarks.
Ich kann mal aufzählen, die Physiker sind nicht besonders innovativ,
wenn sie neue Namen geben.
Da gibt es einen Up-Quark und einen Down-Quark und daraus besteht unsere gesamte
Welt. Ich kann zwei Up-Quarks nehmen und einen Down-Quark, dann habe ich drei
Quarks und das ist ein Proton.
Ich kann andersherum zwei Down-Quarks nehmen, einen Up-Quark,
auch wieder drei Quarks, dann habe ich einen Neutron.
Da nehme ich noch das Elektron dazu und damit kann ich vom Wasserstoffatom bis
zum Blei oder Uranatom das komplette Periodensystem bauen.
Alles zusammenbauen und das ist unsere Welt, aus der wir auch bestehen,
wo aus dieser Tisch hier besteht.
Und die Natur hat es aber so eingerichtet, dass es noch eine zweite und dritte
Generation oder Familie, das sind Synonyme, man kann beides nehmen, sagen, gibt.
Und kein Mensch weiß, warum es jetzt eine zweite und eine dritte Generation gibt.
Es gibt auch genau drei, auch das wurde am LAC untersucht, auch bei anderen Beschleunigern.
Gibt es denn nicht noch eine vierte, fünfte, sechste Familie?
Gibt es nicht. Zumindest nicht bei den Energien, die uns momentan zur Verfügung stehen.
Und das ist eines der großen Rätsel im Standardmodell der Deutschmusik.
Warum gibt es drei Familien und genau drei und nicht mehr und nicht weniger?
So und dann kommen wir zur starken Wechselwirkung. Die Protonen,
diese Quarks, werden zusammengehalten von der starken Wechselwirkung.
Wir kennen ja aus der Schule, aus dem Alltag, die elektromagnetische Wechselwirkung,
elektrische Ladungen, magnetische Felder.
Wir kennen die Schwerkraft, die, die Gravitation, die hat gespielt keine Rolle
im Standardmodell der Teilchenphysik, die wird nicht berücksichtigt.
Aber es gibt noch zwei im Standardmodell, zwei weitere mikroskopische Kräfte,
das ist die schwache Kernkraft oder die schwache Kraft, Die ist zum Beispiel
dafür verantwortlich, dass ein Neutron zerfällt in ein Proton und ein Elektron und ein Neutrino.
Und dann gibt es noch eine Kraft, das ist eben die starke Kraft.
Und diese beiden Kernkräfte haben sehr kurze Reichweiten. Wir wissen ja von
der elektromagnetischen Wechselwirkung, die geht unendlich weit.
Oder wir sehen, wir spüren die Schwerkraft der Sonne, die 150 Millionen Kilometer
von uns entfernt ist, spüren wir, weil die Erde sich eben um die Sonne bewegt.
Und diese Kernkräfte haben sehr, sehr kurze Reichweiten, also sehr viel kleiner
als die Größe von einem Atom.
Deshalb sind die so schwierig zu sehen.
Und deswegen sind sie ja auch im Fokus.
Okay, und inwiefern, also was ist jetzt sozusagen die konkrete Perspektive von Alice?
Also Alice versucht es quasi so zu betrachten,
dass man eben dadurch, dass man diese schweren Bleiatome beziehungsweise nicht die Atome,
sondern die Kerne, die Bleikerne kollidieren lässt und diese extreme Teilchendichte
zu erzeugen und dann hat man sozusagen die Hoffnung und die Erwartung und mittlerweile
wahrscheinlich auch schon die Erkenntnis,
dass man daraus dann Schlüsse ziehen kann auf das Wesen dieser Elementarteilchen und dieser Kräfte.
Ja, dazu dient, dass ich soweit ausgeholt habe. Diese Quarks,
die in den Protonen eingeschlossen sind, die tragen jetzt eine Farbladung,
so wie ein Elektron eine elektrische Ladung trägt.
Und diese Ladung ist ja Ursache für eine Kraft. Die elektrische Ladung ist die
Ursache für die elektromagnetische Kraft, dass sich ein Proton und ein Elektron anziehen.
Und so tragen die Quarks, die tragen auch elektrische Ladung,
aber die tragen auch Farbladung und das ist Ursache für die starke Kraft.
Und jetzt ist es so, ein freies Elektron können wir beobachten oder wir haben
das sogar in dem Collider, vor dem Lärmschadung Collider hatten wir Elektronen
und sogar Positronen, freie Teilchen im Ring, die wir beschleunigen konnten.
Wir können auch Lichtteilchen, die von der Sonne kommen, können über sehr große
Distanzen sich fortbewegen bis zu uns, zur Erde, bis zu unserem Auge und werden dort dann detektiert.
Die Quarks, aufgrund der Tatsache, dass die jetzt noch diese starke Farbladung
tragen, dass die in der starken Wechselwirkung teilnehmen, diese Quarks ist
es uns noch nie gelungen, ein freies Quark zu beobachten.
Also die sind eingeschlossen in diesem Proton und egal was man tut,
Leuten 40, 50 Jahre lang.
Stark danach geschaut, irgendwo im Experiment mal freie Quarks zu beobachten, das ist nie geschehen.
Woher wusste man denn, dass es denn Quarks gibt, wenn man sie nicht beobachten kann?
Ah ja, das ist eine interessante Frage, das war in den 1960er Jahren,
hat man die Struktur von einem Proton oder auch von Atomkern untersucht,
mithilfe von Elektronenstreuung.
Das Elektron ist ja ein Elementarteilchen, das hat selbst keine Struktur,
das hat also keine Breite, keine Höhe, keine Länge.
Es hat keine Dimension. Es ist punktförmig nach allem, was wir wissen.
Wir haben noch nie festgestellt, dass das Elektron noch eine Unterstruktur hat
und irgendwie ausgedehnt ist.
Zumindest mit der experimentellen Auflösung, die wir heute erreichen,
die mehr als tausend Mal besser ist als die Größe vom Proton.
Also ein Elektron ist punktförmig im Standardmodell.
Und mit diesen Elektronen, die hat man auf Protonen geschossen und aus dem gestreuten
Elektron dann über die Struktur des Protons einen Aufschluss erhalten.
Das kann man sich vorstellen, wie wenn die Leute ein Einzelspalt-Experiment kennen.
Wenn ich mit Licht auf eine Struktur leuchte, sehe ich, wenn die Lichtwelle
ungefähr die Größe hat von dem Spalt oder von dem Teilchen, das ich untersuche,
dann sehe ich Beugungseffekte.
Dann sehe ich eben nicht nur Licht und Schatten, sondern ich sehe Beugungseffekte im Licht.
Und daraus kann ich auf die Größe des Deichens schließen. Das hat man gemacht
mit Elektronen, also mit Materiewellen.
Die Materiewellen haben sehr viel kürzere Wellenlängen als normales Licht,
das uns zur Verfügung steht.
Und dann hat man nicht nur das Licht gebeugt, man hat auch, das nennen die Physiker,
inelastische Kollisionen gemacht.
Das hat man mit sehr hohen Energien auch wieder an einen Beschleuniger,
der damals die höchsten Energien zur Verfügung gestellt hat,
mit Elektronen, die viel Energie hatten, auf den Proton geschossen und aus diesem
Streumuster schließen können,
dass hier Elementarteilchen mit einer bestimmten Ladung im Proton sind,
genauso wie Radaford das vor über 100 Jahren mit am Goldkern gemacht hat mit Alpha-Teilchen.
Er hat also ein Streuexperiment gemacht bei hohen Energien und dann gesehen,
aha, die Proton haben noch eine innere Struktur.
Weil sie nicht sich punktförmig verhalten, sondern in irgendeiner Form aus etwas
anderem komponiert sind?
Man hat genau gesehen, das Proton ist ja ausgedehnt, das verhält sich nicht
punktförmig und dann hat man gemerkt, wenn man zu sehr, sehr hohen Energien
geht, sieht das so aus, als würde man wieder an einem punktförmigen Teilchen streuen.
Und das sind diese punktförmigen Quarks mit einer Elementarladung von plus zwei
Drittel der Elektronenladung oder minus zwei Drittel.
Nur isoliert hat man sie halt nicht bekommen, die Quarks. Vielen Dank.
Und das ist das, was Ellis dann versucht.
Genau. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt, dazu gibt es auch Rechnungen und schon seit
den Anfangen der 1970er Jahren Vorhersagen,
wenn man jetzt Kernmaterie genügend aufheizt und oder gleichzeitig komprimiert,
also zusammendrückt, dann wird dieser Einschluss zumindest für kurze Zeit aufgehoben.
Und dieser Einschluss, wenn man Kernmaterie auf zwei Billionen Grad Celsius
erhitzt, Dann wird dieser Einschluss wieder aufgehoben und die Quarks und Gluon
können sich quasi frei bewegen über ein relativ großes Volumen.
Beim Collider kann man sich das so vorstellen, wenn ich jetzt Apfelsin habe
und mache die in eine Aldi-Tüte und stoße diese zwei Aldi-Tüten mit möglichst
hoher Geschwindigkeit zusammen,
mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit und dann mache ich die Tüte auf, dann sind diese Apfelsin,
das die Protonen und Neutronen sind, die sind dann nicht mehr da,
sondern da ist nur noch der Saft da.
Und das ist unsere Ursuppe, die aus Quarks und Gluten besteht.
Das Quark, Glut und Plasma?
Ganz genau.
Also sozusagen ein neuer Zustand, den man so im Normalzustand nicht antrifft,
sondern der nur stattfindet, wenn besonders hohe Energien darauf angewendet werden.
Ganz genau. Und der Zugang zur Kosmologie ist folgender, das Olimersium dehnt
sich ja aus seit seiner Entstehung, seit dem Urknall.
Das heißt, heute sind wir ungefähr 13,8 Milliarden Jahre nach dem Urknall.
Das Universum hat sich sehr stark abgekühlt.
Wenn ich jetzt die Zeit zurückdrehe, würde sich das Universum wieder zusammenschrumpfen
und es wird immer dichter und heißer.
Und ungefähr wenige Millionsel Sekunden nach dem Urknall war das Universum eben
so heiß, dass da keine Atomkerne bestehen konnten. Selbst die Bausteine der
Atomkerne, die Protonen, Neutronen konnten nicht bestehen, weil die Temperaturen so hoch waren.
Das heißt, die gesamte Materie, die wir heute sehen, aus der wir auch bestehen,
aus der unsere Erde entsteht, aus der die Sonne besteht,
Die ganze sichtbare Materie, die wir heute sehen, die lag in so einem Zustand
vor, dass wir Quark-Gluten-Plasma nennen.
Die gesamte Materie lag, wenn Sie so wollen, als Suppe aus Quark und Gluten vor.
Und wir versuchen jetzt am Large Hadron Collider so ein kleines Tropfen dieser
Ursuppe wieder herzustellen.
Also sozusagen so ein Blick in den Urknall, könnte man fast sagen.
Ich meine, die ganze Urknalltheorie ist ja wirklich bestechend,
weil sie ja in gewisser Hinsicht viel von dem erklärt, was wir heute sehen und
dieses Gedankenexperiment, quasi das Universum in der Zeit rückwärts laufen
zu lassen, hat ja schon zu so einigen Vorhersagen geführt.
Und wenn man sich mal vorstellt,
heute haben wir halt so ein sich ausdehnendes Universum und wir falten das jetzt
sozusagen wieder zusammen,
dann wird's halt erstmal kleiner und langsamer,
jetzt wird's ja immer schneller, Es wird kleiner,
langsamer, verdichtet sich irgendwann, man hatte dann,
jetzt hab ich die Zahl vergessen, an bestimmten Zahl von Jahren nach dem eigentlichen
Knall diesen Moment, wo alles soweit
sich aufheizt, also normalerweise die Abkühlung jetzt heizt sich auf,
dass gar kein Licht mehr frei fließen kann und das ganze Universum sozusagen undurchsichtig wird.
Und wenn man es jetzt immer weiter komprimiert und die Temperatur immer weiter zunimmt,
sind halt also all diese ganzen Strukturen, wie wir sie heute kennen,
so gar nicht mehr da und alles besteht eigentlich nur noch aus so einer Suppe
aus Elementarteilchen, in diesem Zustand der totalen Hitze nicht in der Lage
sind, sich zu verbinden.
Aber in dem Moment, wo man alles expandiert und sich abkühlt stellen sich sozusagen
diese Verbindungen her und mit die erste Verbindung,
die sich herstellt ist sozusagen, dass die Quarks durch diese Gluonen zusammengehalten
werden und sich damit überhaupt erst Protonen bilden, die dann später zu Atomen werden.
Ganz genau. Dieser Zeitpunkt ist
auch ganz wichtig in der Geschichte des Universums, den du genannt hast.
Nach ungefähr 380.000 Jahren hat sich das Universum soweit abgekühlt durch die
Ausdehnung, durch die Expansion, dass die Protonen sich Elektronen eingefangen
haben. Dann gab es also elektrisch neutrale Atome.
Und erst ab dem Zeitpunkt wurde das Universum durchsichtig oder transparent
für Licht, für Photonen.
Vorher wurden die ständig von diesen Elektronen und Protonen absorbiert, wieder emittiert.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt war das Universum also opak, undurchsichtig.
Und erst nach 380.000 Jahren, als sich die meisten Teilchen dann als elektrisch-neutrale
Atome zusammengefunden haben, wurde das Universum transparent.
Also das Licht, das wir vom Urknall sehen, entstand 380.000,
Jahre nach dem Urknall und wir können nicht weiter in die Vergangenheit zurückschauen,
weil das Universum opaq war und mit so einem Quark-Klon-Plasma kommen wir bis
wenigste Millionstel Sekunden an den Urknall ran.
Also viel, viel weiter zurück in die Entwicklung des Universums.
Jetzt natürlich die Frage, wie baut man sowas? Wie kriegt man das hin?
Hin, weil die Kollision alleine mag das ja, also ich weiß gar nicht,
was man sozusagen bauen muss, um überhaupt die Kollision zu ermöglichen und
dann vor allem wie kriegt man das Ganze beobachtet.
Wie ist so ein Detektor aufgebaut, wie groß ist der?
Also groß, der ist sehr groß. Unser Detektor ist 16 Meter hoch,
10 Meter breit, 10 Meter tief und der ist um die Wechselwirkungszone,
wie wir sie nennen, also der Bereich,
in dem beide Strahlen, Teilchenstrahlen, am Large Hadron Collider zusammenstoßen.
Das heißt, die Teilchenstrahlen sind erstmal unabhängig, die laufen im Strahlohr,
das evakuiert ist, da ist ein Ultra-Hochvakuum drin, 10 minus 11 Millibar.
Und ein Strahl, ein Teilchenstrahl, das sind also Bündel von Teilchen,
Bündel von Protonen oder Bündel von Atomkernen, von nackten Atomkernen,
die laufen im Irr-Uhrzeigersinn.
Und beim Collider habe ich einen zweiten Teilchenstrahl, der läuft eben gegen dem Uhrzeigersinn.
Und da, wo die Experimente stehen, da werden die Strahlen überkreuzt und zur Kollision gebracht.
Und um diese Kollisionszone bauen wir einen Detektor herum, um eben die neuen
Teilchen, die in der Kollision entstehen, nachweisen zu können.
Wir wollen wissen, was sind das für Teilchen, welchen Impuls haben die?
Und was sind das für Teilchen? Ist das ein Pion, ein Proton oder irgendein anderes
Teilchen aus dem Super-Thoma und so, die das ganze griechische Alphabet bevölkern.
Okay, aber wie, was muss man jetzt bauen und warum muss das Ding 16 Meter groß sein?
Ja, also so ein Teilchen, wenn es aus der Kollisionszone kommt,
jetzt sagen wir die Bleikerne stoßen zusammen und dann, unser Detektor sitzt
ja praktisch senkricht zur Strahlrichtung. Das Strahlrauer ist ja gerade in der Kollisionszone.
Natürlich ist der Ladschadonkollein ein Ring, aber entlang der Kollisionszone
ist das gerade. Und um diese Kollisionszone herum bauen wir den Detektor.
Jetzt wird ein Teilchen in der Kollision, in diesem Ultrahochwakuum erzeugt.
Dann macht sich das auf den Weg zu unserem Detektor. Das Erste,
was es sieht, ist das Strahlrohr.
Das muss ja durch das Strahlrohr durch. Im Strahlrohr ist Hochvakuum.
Außerhalb vom Strahlrohr ist normaler Druck. Da können wir beide hingehen und
uns den Detektor angucken und den reparieren oder was Neues einbauen.
Das heißt, es muss erst durch das Strahlrohr durch. Und was wir,
speziell in ALICE, aber das machen auch die anderen Experimente,
tun ist, wir wollen möglichst niederenergetische, wir wollen möglichst alle Teilchen nachweisen.
Das heißt, wir wollen die messen, aber möglichst wenig stören.
Jede Materie, die das Teilchen auf dem Weg zum Detektor und Limit-Detector durchdringen
muss, stört das Teilchen. Das verliert Energie, das weicht ein bisschen von
seiner Bahn ab, die es ursprünglich hatte. Also wir versuchen möglichst minimalinversiv
die Teilchen nachzuweisen.
Jetzt geht das durch das Strahlor durch. Das heißt, allein das Strahlor ist
schon ein Hightech-Ausrüstungsgegenstand.
Das wird aus extrem stabilen und leichtem Material gebaut, aus Beryllium.
Dass eben die Teilchen möglichst wenig gestört werden. Allein das Strahlor kostet
schon eine Million Schweizer Franken.
Und das ist sehr, sehr brüchig. Das heißt, wenn wir den Detektor upgraden oder
erarbeiten, nehmen wir das Strahlor raus oder schützen es so,
dass wenn einer mit dem Helm dran stößt oder aus Versehen da drankommt,
dass das nicht kaputt geht.
Weil das Beryllium ist so ein brüchiges Material.
Es ist sehr brüchig, giftig und
toxisch und hat aber natürlich sehr gute Eigenschaften für die Teilchen.
Ja, sehr brüchig. Ich denke, man könnte das durch einen leichten Stoß mit einem
harten Gegenstand sofort zerstören.
Okay.
So, und dann hat es das Strahlrohr durchdrungen und dann kommt schon sehr knapp
nach dem Strahlrohr, wir versuchen auch möglichst nah an der Kollisionszone
schon die Teilchen nachzuweisen.
Dann haben wir einen langen Hebelarm später, wenn wir das Teilchen,
den Impuls zum Beispiel bestimmen.
Und da sitzen dann Siliziumdetektoren, das heißt das sind sehr dünne Lagen von
Silizium und wenn das Teilchen durchgeht, macht es wieder das gleiche wie es
ein Strahlung macht, es deponiert Energie.
Das ist einfach, das Teilchen ist elektrisch geladen und das wechselwirkt vor
allem mit den Elektronen aus der Atommülle oder aus dem Festkörper von Silizium.
Wechselwirkt das und deponiert da wie eine Energie durch die elektromagnetische Wechselwirkung.
Und diese Energie, die im Detektor deponiert wird, die weisen wir nach.
Das heißt, ich habe da Elektronen, die kann ich verstärken und am Ende habe
ich eine Pulshöhe, die ich messe und dann digitalisiere.
Also das Teilchen bewirkt letzten Endes einen Strom, der in diesem System fließt?
Ja, einen Strom oder einen Spannungspuls, genau.
Strom über den Widerstand ist eine Spannung.
Das klingt jetzt alles sehr klein.
Warum ist das dann 16 Meter groß?
Ja, wir messen jetzt, wir wollen das Teilchen nicht nur nachweisen,
wir wollen auch sehen, welchen Impuls hat das, also welche Energie hat das Teilchen.
Oder fangen wir beim Impuls an.
Das heißt, die Messtechnik ist folgende, das ist an allen Experimenten gleich,
bei den Spurdetektoren.
Wir legen ein Magnetfeld an und ein geladenes Teilchen, wenn man sich an die
Schule erinnert, spürt im Magnetfeld, wird das auf eine Kreisbahn gezwungen.
Das ist die Lorentz-Kraft.
Und wenn ich also das Magnetfeld sehr gut kenne und die Spur,
ich messe die Spur, ich messe mit meinen Detektoren sukzessive bestimmte Punkte
entlang der Teilchenbahn, was das Teilchen nimmt,
dann kann ich den Radius, den Krümmungsradius von dieser Kreisbahn,
dass das Teilchen nimmt im Magnetfeld, sehr genau messen.
Ich mache also eine Ortsmessung und aus dem Krümmungsradius kenne ich dann den Impuls.
Über was für Distanzen reden wir jetzt hier, die diese Teilchen da jetzt durchschlagen?
Also unser Detektor, der Siliziumdetektor ist vielleicht 50,
60 Zentimeter im Radius. Das ist so eine Tonne, sehr leicht.
Ist 50 Zentimeter im Radius in verschiedenen Lagen. Die erste kommt bei etwa
2 Zentimetern, das geht dann hoch bis 60, 70 Zentimeter und ist vielleicht zwei Meter lang.
Zwei bis vier Meter lang.
Verschiedene Lagen von Silizium?
Das ist die gleiche Technologie.
Und das Silizium liegt jetzt, wie muss man sich das vorstellen,
so als Blätter oder als Rohre oder als solide Masse?
Ja ein Rohr ist schon ein guter Punkt, weil unsere Geometrie ist zylindrisch.
Das heißt der Detektor hat auch eine zylindrische Form.
Das sind Leitern, das sind einzelne Lagen von Silizium,
die quasi in so einer Faske, im Englischen sagen wir dazu Barrel,
das hat eine zylindrische Form und da tun wir einzelne Lagen von Silizium bei
bestimmten Radien anbringen, wo das Teilchen dann durchgeht.
Dieses Silizium ist sehr dünn. Das sind ungefähr 50 Millionen Meter.
Das sind sehr, sehr dünne Siliziumlagen, wie gesagt, um das Teilchen möglichst wenig zu stören.
Ja, okay. Gut. Also muss ich das, ich will jetzt nicht Alufolie sagen, aber das...
Alufolie ist viel dicker. Alufolie ist 100 Mikrometer, 150 Mikrometer. Aber so ist das...
Okay, aber wir reden jetzt nicht von Platten und dicken, fetten Gehäusen,
sondern wirklich sehr dünne Schichten von dem Material.
Genau. Also unser Detektor ist zwar riesig, aber der aktive Detektor,
in dem die Teilchen nachgewiesen werden, der ist so leicht, der würde sogar in Milch schwimmen.
Um ein populäres Bild zu bedienen.
Die Älteren kennen das noch, meine Kinder kennen das.
Ich habe es auch schon mal gehört. Ja, okay. Also das ist so diese innerste
Schicht, die sozusagen, das ist das erste, was man sozusagen beobachtet ist. Wo fliegt's lang?
Und dadurch, dass das Teilchen dann mehrere dieser Schichten durchschlägt,
kann man sehen, wo es lang fliegt. Also man hat sozusagen auf jeder dieser Folien
quasi so eine zweidimensionale Ortungsmöglichkeit.
Man sieht wo es genau aufschlägt.
Ganz genau. Es sind aber drei, weil ich ja weiß, wo der Detektor steht,
bei welchem Radius. Also ich messe wirklich in drei Dimensionen die Teilstrecke.
Dadurch auf welcher Folie es aufschlägt. Das ist dann die dritte Dimension.
Aber pro Folie erreicht man diese zwei. Wie kann man merken, wo es genau aufschlägt?
Die Siliziumlage hat eine Granularität und diese Folie ist segmentiert in was wir Pixel nennen.
Und diese Pixel haben eine Größe von momentan, wir haben gerade ein wesentliches
Upgrade vom Detektor gemacht, wir haben unseren alten Siliziumdetektor rausgeschmissen.
Der steht jetzt in der Ausstellung, können wir uns angucken,
wenn du nachher Zeit hast.
Und jetzt ist das alles aus Siliziumpixelsensoren gebaut und diese Pixel haben
eine Größe, also das ist die zweidimensionale Messung von 30 x 30 Mikrometer.
Also sie sind 30 Mikrometer lang in x- und y-Richtungen, in zwei Richtungen.
Wenn dieser Pixel jetzt anspricht, weiß ich, das Teilchen muss durch dieses
Segment gelaufen sein und ich kenne tatsächlich dann die Position sehr viel
besser als 20 Mikrometer, es sind vielleicht dann 8 Mikrometer oder so.
Also durch die Granularität dieser einzelnen Pixel, dass das segmentiert ist,
Diese Siliziumfolie ist segmentiert in sehr sehr kleine Pixel.
Dadurch kommt die Hoher Ortshauflösung.
Aber was führt dazu, dass man das in einem Pixel detektieren kann?
Also geht von jedem Pixel noch irgendwie nochmal ein...
Draht weg? Natürlich. Okay, also das ist sozusagen… Ah gut, ja.
Das ist ja dann sehr dünn der Draht.
Ja, ja, das ist die hohe Kunst. Und wir haben den, würde ich sagen,
den modernsten Siliziumdetektor, den es gibt in der Welt. Den haben wir gerade eingebaut.
Dieser Pixel ist wie gesagt 20 oder 30 mal 30 Mikrometer in der Ausdehnung und
dann hat er eine Dicke von vielleicht 50 Mikrometern.
Und jetzt schlägt das geladene Teilchen da durch, deponiert also Energie,
kreiert freie Elektronenlochpaare und diese werden gesammelt und diese Elektronen,
die frei werden, werden wieder eingesammelt und machen dann ein elektrisches
Signal, das sich verstärken kann mit Elektronik.
Und das passiert alles auf diesem Mini-Chip.
Also die ganze Digitalisierung passiert auf dem Chip, die Auslöse-Elektronik
ist Teil dieses Pixel-Chips.
Und dann geht natürlich eine Datenleitung raus ans Ende des Detektors,
ans seitliche Ende und dann werden die Daten weggeschickt per Glasfaserkabel.
Das heißt, das ist alles schon digitalisiert. Was aus unserem Detektor rauskommt
sind nur Nullen und Einsen.
Ja, ich meine deswegen heißt es ja auch Pixel, letzten Endes ist es ein Bildelement,
das heißt ja Pixel, in dem Fall halt ein dreidimensionales Bildelement und das
dann eben auch über die Zeit im Verlauf.
Also man kann sowohl den Ort als auch die Geschwindigkeit damit messen.
Also zunächst misst man erst mal nur den Ort und die Geschwindigkeit misst man
ja, eigentlich hat man dann vier Dimensionen, die Drei-Raum-Dimensionen und die Zeit, das stimmt.
Wenn ich den Kollisionszeitpunkt genau bestimme, kann ich die Zeit messen bis
mein Pixeldetektor anspricht, dann weiß ich wie lange das Teilchen von seiner
Entstehung vom Kollisionsort bis zum Detektor gebraucht hat.
Und dann kenne ich die Flugzeit.
Und das ist auch eine relevante Information?
Natürlich, wir haben auch einen speziellen Flugzeitdetektor,
sehr viel weiter draußen bei 3,70 Meter Radius.
Und man möchte natürlich die Flugzeit möglichst lange machen,
dass man bei einer bestimmten Zeitauflösung relativ ist, dann die Auflösung
sehr viel besser. Je länger die Flugstrecke ist, desto länger ist die Flugzeit.
Und wie gesagt, den Impuls habe ich schon bestimmt über die Krümmung im Magnetfeld.
Und jetzt habe ich noch die Geschwindigkeit gemessen durch eine Flugzeitmessung.
Und Impuls ist Masse mal Geschwindigkeit im Klassischen.
Das heißt, wenn ich Impuls und Geschwindigkeit bestimme, weiß ich,
welche Masse das Teilchen hat. Und bei Teilchen ist es so.
Die haben eine ganz bestimmte Masse, die sich auch nie ändert.
Das ist also ein Fingerabdruck für ein Teilchen, welche Masse das hat.
Du und ich, unser Gewicht ändert sich im Laufe unseres Lebens,
aber für ein Teilchen ist das immer gleich.
Und das heißt, wenn ich die Teilchenmasse kenne, weiß ich, welches Teilchen
das ist. Dann weiß ich, war es ein Proton, war es ein Pion oder sonst was.
Und was kann man der Bahn ansehen dann?
Den Impuls. Damit misst man den Impuls.
Aber letzten Endes Ziel ist eigentlich nur die Masse, also anhand der Bahn,
weil man dann Bahn und Impuls auseinander halten kann, also Zeit und Impuls
auseinander halten kann, kommt man auf die Masse und damit weiß man welches Teilchen es ist.
Das ist also letzten Endes die einzige Information, die ich gewinne,
welche Teilchen entstehen.
Wo die dann lang fliegen ist eigentlich gar nicht interessant,
weil das nur das Hilfsmittel ist, um rauszufinden, worum es sich handelt.
Nein, das ist der erste Schritt. Ich bestimme ja das Teilchen,
den Impuls und auch die Richtung. Ich bestimme die Pulsrichtung,
also nicht nur die Größe. Ein Puls ist ja ein Vektor, der hat drei Richtungen.
Also ich weiß auch, in welche Richtung das Teilchen geflogen ist von seiner Entstehung aus.
Also kinematisch habe ich dann das Teilchen vollständig bestimmt.
Ich weiß genau den Impuls und was es ist, was für ein Teilchen es ist.
Und dann kann ich bei diesen 20.000 Teilchen, die bei uns in der Kollision entstehen,
kann ich das mit anderen Teilchen korrelieren.
Ich kann die gesamte kinematische Information benutzen und dann eben Korrelation
zwischen einem und weiteren Teilchen bestimmen und dann zum Beispiel die Wechselwirkung
zwischen diesen beiden Teilchen studieren.
Das ist ganz wichtig, um Neutronensterne zu verstehen.
Ich kann dann die Wechselwirkung, die starke Wechselwirkung zwischen diesen
beiden Teilchen untersuchen.
Okay, zu den wissenschaftlichen Auswertungen oder den Schlussfolgerungen kommen
wir vielleicht noch dazu.
Aber wir haben ja jetzt wie viele Zentimeter an Technologie gerade jetzt beschrieben von innen?
Von innen haben wir zunächst das Strahlrohr, das kommt so nach zwei Zentimetern
oder 1,8 Zentimetern Flugrichtung in radiale Richtung.
Dann kommt der Silizium-Detektor, da bin ich bei etwa 70 cm Entfernung vom Kollisionsvertex.
Und dann kommt, salopp gesagt, eine große Tonne, das ist unsere Zeitprojektionskammer,
und die ist mit Gas gefüllt. Also die hat eine sehr, sehr geringe Dichte, das ist der Grund.
Ein Gas hat ungefähr 100 bis 1000 Mal weniger Dichte und damit Material als
ein Festkörper, als Silizium.
Und diese Tonne geht von 80 cm Radius bis 2,50 m.
Also das ist der radiale Abmessung, das heißt diese Zeitprojektionskammer hat
einen Durchmesser von fünf Metern.
Was ist da für ein Gas drin?
Da ist ein Edelgas drin, das haben alle Gasdetektoren. Das heißt in diesem Gas
passiert etwas sehr ähnliches wie im Siliziumdetektor.
Das geladene Teilchen fliegt durch dieses Gas und knockt da Elektronen aus dem Edelgas raus.
Das heißt, da entstehen freie Ladungsträger, die Elektronen,
und die werden mit einem elektrischen Feld abgesaugt.
Da legen wir 100.000 Volt an und dann driften diese Elektronen in Richtung der
Endkappe von unserer großen Tonne.
Und durch den Auftreffpunkt wissen wir schon wieder die X- und Y-Koordinate.
Das heißt, nachdem man so die ursprüngliche Ableitung,
die durch dieses am Zentrum des Detektors befindlichen Magnetfelds beobachten kann,
dann fliegt es mehr oder weniger gerade weiter und innerhalb dieser Time Projection
Chamber heißt es glaube ich, TPC, geht es eigentlich nur darum,
eine gerade Flugrichtung, weil dann wird es ja nicht mehr weiter abgelenkt,
dann fliegt es einfach gerade aus?
Ich habe nicht dazu gesagt. Unser gesamter Detektor steckt in einem riesigen
Magneten, das ist der größte warmleitende Magnet der Welt. Das heißt auch in
der Zeitprojektionskammer ist ein Magnetfeld.
Okay.
Ja, also wir haben einen Solenoiden, das heißt eine Spule,
wenn ich einfach eine Spule wickele mit vielen, vielen Windungen und lege dann
Strom an, dann habe ich im Spulen, innerhalb der Spule ein sehr homogenes Magnetfeld,
das entlang der Spulenachse geht.
Und so ist auch unser Magnet gebaut. Das ist ein Solenoid. Also ich habe eine
riesige Kupferspule und die erzeugt ein Magnetfeld, das entlang der Strahlachse geht.
Und in diesem riesigen Magnet befinden sich alle unsere Detektoren.
Und das macht das große Gewicht aus von ALICE, das sind ungefähr 10.000 Tonnen.
Das ist einfach der Stahl aus dem Rückflussjoch des Magneten.
Der Magnet wiegt 10.000 Tonnen.
Okay, aber ich als kollidierendes Teilchen bin ja sozusagen immer noch auf meinem
Weg von der Mitte nach wo auch immer es mich leitet.
Ich bin jetzt also sozusagen von diesen inneren Magnetfeldern nach der Kollision abgelenkt worden,
habe diverse Schichten Siliziumfolie sehr dünn durchschlagen,
dabei meine Spur hinterlassen sozusagen gesagt,
wo ich jetzt lang geflogen bin und letzten Endes habe ich mich dadurch auch
schon verraten, was ich eigentlich bin und jetzt fliege ich irgendwie weiter
durch diese Time Projection Chamber, die diese Gas gefüllte Kugel?
Zylinder. Und ein Zylinder drumherum,
also auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt noch mal ein paar Meter vor mir durch Gas
und was genau kann man da messen?
Also misst man nur wo es auftrifft letzten Endes am Ende dieser Kammer oder
ist das schon auch eine Beobachtung innerhalb des Weges dort?
Ja, also wir sind immer noch im Magnetfeld. Ich bin immer noch auf einer gekrümmten
Spur und ich messe 159 Punkte entlang dieser Spur in diesem Gas.
Aber wie kann man denn in dem Gas was messen? Da gibt es doch keine Drähte.
Ganz genau. Das ist der große Vorteil von der Zeitprojektionskammer.
Ich habe da auch keine toten Zonen. Ich bin aktiv im gesamten Gas.
Also noch mal das geladene Teilchen geht durchs Gas, ionisiert diese Gasatome,
also schlägt Elektronen raus, entlang seiner Teilchenspuren.
Jetzt habe ich entlang dieser Spur überall Elektronen.
Jetzt lege ich ein elektrisches Feld an und zwar auch wieder in Richtung der
Strahlaxe. Das heißt, diese Teilchenspur wird dann, diese Elektronen werden
dann Richtung Endkappe beschleunigt.
Das ist so, wie wenn ich in den Himmel schaue und sehe ein Flugzeug,
ein schweres Flugzeug mit Jetantrieb.
Dann kann ich gucken, im Himmel habe ich Kondensstreifen. Und auch wenn das
Flugzeug schon lange weg ist, kann ich immer noch sagen, welchen Weg das Flugzeug
genommen hat, indem ich den Kondensstreifen anschaue. Und bei uns im Detektorgas
ist das die Ionisationsspur.
Das ist einfach diese Wolke von Elektronen, die entlang der teilschen Spuren entstehen.
Und jetzt kann ich da natürlich nicht mit dem Auge reingucken.
Ich nehme ein elektrisches Feld und die Elektronen werden dann in Richtung Endkappe.
Die gesamten Elektronen entlang der teilschen Spur werden in Richtung meiner
Endkappe über eine Distanz von 2,50 Meter transportiert und kommen dann an der Endkappe an.
Und da habe ich dann wieder Auslesesegmente, die eben diese auftreffenden Elektronen
detektieren und das ist segmentiert in der Art und Weise,
dass ich eben an dieser Endkabel 100 bis zu 159 Segmente habe,
die diese ankommenden Elektronen detektieren.
Erklärt für mich auch gerade so ein bisschen wieder mal, warum einfach diese
enormen Beschleunigungen eigentlich erforderlich sind,
damit halt auch noch diese rausgesprengten Teilchen am Schluss so viel Alarm
machen können, dass sie irgendwie über so über Meter hinweg so viel Nebenwirkungen
erzeugen, dass man die sogar noch messen kann.
Um genau zu sein, passiert mit den Elektronen gar nichts. Die werden nur transportiert
von ihrer Entstehung bis an die Endkappe. Sonst passiert mit den Elektronen nichts.
Ja gut, aber sie müssen ja auch erst mal freigeschlagen werden.
Das macht das Teilchen.
Das macht das Teilchen. Dazu muss das Teilchen aber auch ordentlich Performance am Start haben.
Ja, wenn man jetzt so schaut, aus der Schule kennt man das vielleicht,
um ein Elektron abzulösen von einem Atom, braucht man die Größenordnung,
Unsere Einheit ist Elektronenvolt, braucht man in Größenordnung paar Kilo Elektronenvolt.
Unsere Teilchen haben Milliarden Elektronenvolt. Also der Energieverlust,
den die Teilchen erleiden, indem sie Elektronen rausschrauben, ist minimal.
Den kann man fast vernachlässigen. Das heißt, wir kriegen also primäre Elektronen,
die kommen aus der Ionisation des Gases, durch das ursprüngliche Teilchen.
Die müssen wir dann noch verstärken und das passiert an den Endkappen.
Und da haben wir dann Zeldrähte, wo eben ein sehr starkes, hohes elektrisches
Feld erzeugen, dass man so eine Lawine von weiteren Elektronen erzeugen kann.
Also die Signalverstärkung passiert erst am Ende.
Und warum ist jetzt diese Kammer so wertvoll und warum ist die noch da?
Man hat ja im Prinzip den Weg und die Kurve sozusagen und auch schon die Bestimmung,
worum es sich handelt und was der Impuls ist, hat man ja im Prinzip schon.
Was ist sozusagen auf diesen zusätzlichen Metern noch der weitere Informationsgewinn?
Ändert sich da noch viel dran?
Ja, erst mal je länger ich diese Spur verfolge, desto größer ist meine Auflösung,
also desto präziser kann ich den Impuls bestimmen.
Das ist einfach ein Hebelgesetz, wenn man so will. Je länger der Arm ist,
desto stärker meine Kraft und genauso ist das bei einer Teilchenspur.
Die Zeitprojektionskammer misst Spuren über eine Länge von 2,50 Meter.
Der Siliziumdetektor nur über eine Länge von 70 Zentimetern maximal.
Und das führt zu einer sehr, sehr viel besseren Impulsauflösung,
zumindest mit dem Detektor, den wir bisher die letzten zehn Jahre benutzt haben,
also dem Siliziumdetektor.
Und dann ist eine Zeitprojektionskammer. Wir haben ja sehr hohe Teilchenmultiplizitäten.
Wir haben eine sehr hohe Anzahl von geladenen Teilchen im Detektor in diesem
Plei-Plei-Kollision. Und da ist eine Zeitprojektionskammer unschlagbar.
Die kann das am allerbesten solche hohen Multiplizitäten auflösen.
Wir messen, wir meisen jedes einzelne Teilchen nach und wir sagen auch bei jedem
einzelnen Teilchen, was für ein Teilchen das ist. Und das kann am allerbesten
eine Zeitprojektionskammer.
Und das tut man für wie viele Teilchen bei so einer Kollision, wie oft pro Sekunde?
Also wir haben bis zu 20.000 Teilchen pro Kollision.
Und jetzt nach unserem, wir hatten ja zwei Jahre lang Strahlpause am Large Hadron
Collider, seit einem Jahr, seit letztem Jahr messen wir wieder.
Wir haben quasi einen brandneuen Detektor. Die Zeitprojektionskammer ist noch da als Gasvolumen.
Aber die gesamte Auslese an den Endkappen, was praktisch 90 Prozent der Arbeit
ist, die haben wir komplett erneuert mit einer sehr viel schnelleren Auslese,
weil wir jetzt dieses Jahr kriegen wir die ersten Bleikollisionen bei hoher Rate.
Wir werden diese bis zu 20.000 Teilchen 50.000,
mal in der Sekunde kollidieren, zwei Bleikerne im Detektor.
Also es sind gigantische Kollisionsraten für uns und da entstehen auch gigantische Datenvolumen.
Was kommt da für ein Datenstrom raus?
Das ist der Nachteil bei einer Zeitprojektionskammer, die spuckt sehr,
sehr viel Daten aus. Das Datenvolumen ist enorm groß, das macht über 90 Prozent
unseres Datenvolumens aus und die wird liefern 3.500,
Gigabyte pro Sekunde und das 24 Stunden am Tag. 3.500 Gigabyte?
Ja, das sind 3,5 Terabyte pro Sekunde.
3.500 Gigabyte sind 3,5 Terabyte pro Sekunde und wenn wir das einen Monat laufen lassen,
haben wir eine Disk, wo wir die Daten speichern und ein Jahr behalten können
und die ist 100 Petabyte groß, also 100.000 Terabyte.
Ok und eine Datenrate von 35 Terabit pro Sekunde. Das ist schon ganz ordentlich.
Da braucht man eine amtliche Netzwerktechnik auf jeden Fall.
Terabyte. Wir haben Terabyte.
Ja ich hab's auf Bit hochgerechnet, weil das ist ja für Übertragung meistens so die eine.
Also auf jeden Fall eine Menge, also sozusagen viele Festplatten pro Sekunde.
Also es ist so als ob da die ganze Zeit jemand mit Festplatten durch die Gegend fährt.
Also ich habe mal geschaut, wenn ich sehe was der Datenstrom in ganz Europa
ist von 500 Millionen Menschen, das ist weniger.
Im Internet?
Ich glaube da sind alle Sachen dabei, Datastreaming, E-Mail, Internet.
Aber was sozusagen über das Internet geht.
Ja und unser Detektor spuckt da mehr Daten aus. Das heißt wir können das auch
nicht irgendwo hinschicken und analysieren.
Deshalb haben wir bei Alice ein Computerzentrum, eine Compute Farm aufgebaut,
die diese Daten analysiert.
Wie gesagt die kommen vom Detektor schon digital.
Das heißt wir haben keinen Informationsverlust, keinen Qualitätsverlust im Signal
und diese 3500 Gigabyte pro Sekunde reduzieren wir schon in Echtzeit,
also während wir den Detektor betreiben auf 100 Gigabyte pro Sekunde und die
schreiben wir dann auf Disk.
Was wir auf Disk rausschreiben ist ein Faktor fast 40 weniger.
Ja klar, also wenn man da keine Kompression machen würde, aber das lässt sich
glaube ich ganz gut komprimieren dann auch so das Material.
Also wir haben zur Kompression, das ist weitgehend eine verlustfreie Datenkompression,
haben wir 50.000 CPUs, Prozessoren und 2000 grafische Prozessoreinheiten, also GPUs.
Also das was mein Sohn in der Playstation hat, das sind schon sehr gute Grafikkarten,
die eben sehr schnell rechnen müssen, weil sie eben diese sehr aufwendige Grafik rechnen können.
Das heißt, die können sehr gut parallel rechnen, also mehrere Rechenschnitte
in einem Durchgang machen und unsere sind also noch ein bisschen besser,
aber von den gleichen Anbietern, die auch Spiele, PCs herstellen.
Und davon haben wir 2000. Und die machen diese Datenreduktion speziell für die
Zeitprojektionskammer.
Wenn ich jetzt richtig gerechnet habe, sind wir jetzt 5 Meter vom Kollisionsort
weg, fehlen ja noch ein paar Meter.
War es das schon mit der Detektion oder wird noch darüber hinaus auch noch detektiert?
Okay, also wir dürfen nicht Durchmesser und Radius verwechseln.
Das habe ich vorhin schon gemacht.
Durchmesser habe ich gesagt.
Also das Teilchen hat jetzt 2,50 Meter hinter sich, das heißt es verlässt die
Zeitprojektionsgraden.
Dann kommt ein Detektor, der kam ein bisschen später,
also ein Subdetektor, ein Teil von ALICE, den haben wir ein bisschen später
eingebaut und der kann ganz besonders Elektronen identifizieren über einen bestimmten
physikalischen Effekt, wir nennen das Übergangsstrahlung.
Da nimmt man einfach ein Medium, das zwei verschiedene Dielektrizitätskonstanten
hat, Das ist das Epsilon-R, wenn man das in der Schule mit dem Plattenkandensator rechnet.
Auf jeden Fall tut dieser Detektor besonders Elektronen gut selektieren.
Die meisten Teilchen sind stark wechselwirkende, das sind die Pionen und wie sie alle heißen.
Und diese nicht stark wechselwirkenden Teilchen, wie das Elektron oder das Myon,
das ist ja ein schweres Elektron, das ist zweieinhalb mal schwerer als ein Elektron,
die werden nur sehr selten erzeugt und die will man rauspicken.
Die würde man eben selektieren und das kann dieser Detektor,
der dann bei 3,50 Meter Radius kommt.
Oder 2,90 Meter bis 3,50 Meter.
Warum will man die rauspicken, weil die so selten sind?
Die sind selten und die meisten Teilchen, wir messen ja keine freien Quarks,
wir messen auch viele Teilchen,
die sind so kurzlebig, die werden in der Kollision erzeugt.
Sind die langlebigen Pionen, K und Protonen und dann noch Elektronomie und das
ist im Wesentlichen, was man sieht im Detektor.
Und alles andere zerfallen, zum Beispiel auch Teilchen, die diese schweren Quarks
tragen, die Charm-Quarks und Beauty-Quarks und die zerfallen mit einer bestimmten
Wahrscheinlichkeit in Elektronen oder Elektronen-Positron-Paare.
Und wenn man jetzt Elektronen und Positronen selektieren kann,
kann man diese Mutterteilchen wieder rekonstruieren.
Genau aus dem Grund, weil wir alles, was wir mit dem Detektor messen,
kinematisch vollständig bestimmen.
Und das sind besondere Proben für das Quark-Klone-Plasma. Daraus kann ich was
lernen, welche Eigenschaften dieses Quark-Klone-Plasma hat.
Okay, das heißt wir sind jetzt über die 2,50 Meter. Jetzt bin ich wieder beim
Radius. Wie weit hinaus?
Jetzt kommt der Übergangsstrahlungsdetektor. Der geht von 2,70 bis 3 Meter und
dann schließt sich dieser Flugzeitdetektor an.
Also der sagt dann nur noch, aha ich habe ein Teilchen gesehen und macht also
nur noch eine Zeitinformation, wenn ich bei 3,70 Meter in diesen Flugzeugdetektor
einschlage, bei Radius 3,70 Meter.
Ich glaube jetzt habe ich auch ein bisschen die Zahlen durcheinander gemacht.
Der Flugzeugdetektor ist bei 3,70 bis 3,90 Meter.
Der liefert ein sehr genaues Zeitsignal und das kann ich der Teilchenspur zuordnen
und weiß ich, aha dieses Teilchen, das sich auf den Weg gemacht hat,
ist nach dieser Zeit in meinem Flugzeugdetektor angekommen, bei einem Radius von 3,70 Meter.
Ich muss natürlich die Krümmung im Magnetfeld berücksichtigen,
aber ich kenne praktisch die Länge, die Flugzeit, den Weg, den das Teilchen
genommen hat, kenne ich dann sehr genau.
Also den Flugweg und die Flugzeit und dann kenne ich die Geschwindigkeit und
dann weiß ich, wer es war.
Da weiß man, womit man es zu tun hat.
Ganz genau.
Okay, da hab ich gleich noch ein paar Fragen zu den Erwartungen,
aber ich würde gerne noch die Technik fertig bekommen,
weil das ganze ist ja nach so einem Zwiebelschalen-System aufgebaut,
also man hat einfach in der Mitte die inneren Spurdetektoren,
diese Time-Projection-Chamber drumherum und diese weiteren Kaskaden,
die jetzt eben sich nicht mehr um die Spur kümmern, sondern sozusagen nur noch das Timing erfassen.
Und überhaupt sagen, wenn ich jetzt hier noch was detektiere,
dann handelt es sich eben auch um wirklich interessante Teilchen.
Gibt es noch weitere Detektoren oder war es das jetzt?
Ja, vielleicht hätten wir damit anfangen sollen. Zunächst macht man im Inneren
eine Spurrekonstruktion, genau wie du sagst. Und dann sind wir fertig.
Also wir haben Silizium, wir haben die gasgefüllte Kammer, wir haben den Übergangsstrahlungdetektor
und dann den Flugzeitdetektor.
Damit ist die Teilchenspurrekonstruktion beendet. Und danach schließt sich dann
ein elektromagnetisches Kalorimeter an.
Das heißt, wenn ich sehr, sehr hoch energetische Teilchen habe,
Unser Magnetfeld ist nicht besonders hoch, ein halbes Tesla.
Also sehr viel stärker als das Erdmagnetfeld, aber wenn du schaust,
wenn nachher die Leute kommen von Atlas, die haben viel stärkere Magnetfelder.
Das heißt, je höher mein Impuls ist vom Teilchen oder die Energie,
desto weniger ist die Spur gekrümmt und irgendwann wird die ganz gerade und
dann kann ich das gar nicht mehr unterscheiden. Ist das jetzt eine gerade Spur
oder ist da noch eine Krümmung drin?
Und dann hört irgendwann meine Spurrekonstruktion auf. Ich kann natürlich die
Spur immer noch rekonstruieren, aber ich weiß nichts mehr über den Impuls,
weil ich keine Krümmung mehr feststellen kann. Also keinen Unterschied von einer geraden Spur.
Und dann baut man einen Kalorimeter. Kalorimeter heißt, ich deponiere die gesamte
Teilchenenergie in diesem Detektorteil und weiß dann die Gesamtenergie.
Also ein Kalorimeter misst immer die Gesamtenergie von einem Teilchen.
Und damit beende ich sozusagen auch den Flug.
Das war es. Da ist das Teilchen, das ist das Ende.
Okay, es versackt im Kalorimeter und dann weise ich aber sozusagen die Restenergie
oder eigentlich überhaupt die Energie, weil bisher nicht so richtig viel Energie
eingebüßt wurde durch die ganzen Spurbeobachtungen.
Ganz genau.
Und die misst man dann in was? In Kalorien?
In der Teilchenphysikschule ist alles in Energie.
Alles.
Energie ist ein Elektronenvolt. Elektronenvolt kennen wir aus der Schule.
Wenn ich einen Plattenkondensator habe, der macht ein elektrisches Feld, also Plus und Minus.
Und da habe ich einen Volt und da läuft ein Elektron durch, hat danach das Elektron,
die kinetische Energie von einem Elektronenvolt.
Und wir messen alle Energien in Elektronenvolt oder eigentlich in Gigaelektronenvolt.
Das ist so die natürliche Einheit. Milliarden Elektronenvolt.
Okay, und wie viel Elektronenvolt haben die Teilchen, die jetzt da in diese
Kalorimeter einschlagen?
Ein paar wenige Gigaelektronenvolt bis 100 GV vielleicht.
Man kann das auch, das Higgs-Teilchen, das messen wir nicht,
aber das Higgs-Teilchen wiegt 125 Gigaelektronenvolt.
Das Proton wiegt etwa 1 Gigaelektronenvolt. Also das Higgs ist 125 mal schwerer als das Proton.
Wenn das in zwei Photonen zerfällt, haben diese Photonen jeweils 65 GeV, Gigaelektronenvolt.
Also ein paar Zig bis ein paar hundert Giga-Milliarden Elektronenvolt.
Okay, das heißt diese ganzen Kalorimeter sind dann auch das Ende des Detektors.
Das heißt die sind dann auch erst bei 16 Meter Durchmesser.
Ja, ganz genau.
Okay, also nach 8 Metern sozusagen wird die Energie gemessen und dann ist die
Detektion abgeschlossen.
Noch nicht. Da gibt es noch die einzigen Teilchen, die noch durchkommen,
sind die Myonen, die schweren Elektroden.
Die deponieren eben ihre Energie nicht in einem Kalorimeter.
Die gehen quasi durch alles durch. Man kann die Spur sehen durch den Siliziendetektor,
durch die Zeitprojektionskammer.
Die machen ein Signal im Flugzeitdetektor und die werden nicht im Kalorimeter
gestoppt. Das liegt einfach daran, dass die so hohe Masse haben.
Die sind nicht stark wechselwirkend, die werden also nicht in einem hadronischen Kalorimeter gestoppt.
Die sind zwar Leptonen, aber dadurch, dass die so viel Masse haben,
das Elektron macht dem elektromagnetischen Kalorimeter Bremsstrahlung.
Und die Bremsstrahlungsphotonen machen dann wieder Elektronen-Positron-Paare
und die Elektronen-Positron-Paare machen wieder Bremsstrahlung.
Und so geht das unendlich weiter.
Es bildet sich also ein Schauer, das ist ein elektromagnetischer Schauer,
aus Bremsstrahlungsphotonen und Elektronen-Positronen.
Das Myon macht das nicht, weil das so viel schwerer ist. Das heißt, das geht einfach durch.
Wir sehen sogar Myonen von der kosmischen Strahlung bei uns im ALICE,
obwohl wir von 30 Metern Fels geschützt sind vor der kosmischen Strahlung.
Also die Elektronen gehen durch alles durch und wir haben speziell jetzt nicht
in dieser Zylindergeometrie, also senkrig zur Strahlaxe, aber parallel zur Strahlaxe
oder unter Vorwärtswinkeln haben wir noch einen Myon-Spektrometer.
Da machen wir genau das gleiche. Da steckt ein sieben Meter langer Absorber
aus Eisen und Stahl und der filtert alles raus.
Nur die Myonen kommen hinten an und dann stellt man da ein paar Kammern auf,
die eben die Teilchenspuren messen. Und dann weiß ich, da können nur Myonen durchgekommen sein.
Sind diese Myonen jetzt eher selten oder ist das so ein ganz normales Abfallprodukt
bei dem, was da passiert?
Nein, nichts ist Abfall. Das ist alles Signal. Wie gesagt, es gibt besondere
Teilchen, die schwere Quarks tragen und die zerfallen gerne in Elektronenpaare,
Elektronenpositonpaare oder Paare von positiven und negativen Myonen.
Und die möchte ich rekonstruieren, weil das ganz spezielle Sonden sind.
Schwere Quarks sind ganz besondere Sonden für unser Quark-Klon-Plasma.
So jetzt ist ja Sinn und Aufgabe des Detektors ist jetzt primär diese Blei-Ionen-Kollisionen zu beobachten.
Das heißt mal salopp formuliert passiert ja da immer das gleiche.
Jede Kollision ist einzigartig.
Okay, gut. Darauf wollte ich hinaus. Aber man tut eigentlich immer das gleiche
und man kriegt immer wieder andere Ergebnisse.
Das Signal ist ein anderes. Und genau,
zum Beispiel wir brauchen ein paar zigtausend Blei-Blei-Kollisionen,
Ob das da mal ein Teilchen rauskommt, das aus zwei schweren Quarks besteht und
dann noch zerfällt in ein Elektron-Bosyton-Paar zum Beispiel.
Und die gilt es zu selektieren. Das heißt wir bauen einen Trigger.
Wir triggern auf ein ganz spezielles Ereignis, das nur sehr selten passiert.
Und das ist ja sozusagen das Ding. Also es geht ja hier um Wahrscheinlichkeiten.
Also jetzt könnte man sagen okay no two collisions are the same.
Also obwohl wir eigentlich im Prinzip immer dasselbe tun, mit derselben Apparatur
messen, messen wir eigentlich jedes mal ein komplett anderes Gesamtergebnis.
Also vielleicht nicht komplett anders, sondern es ist vielleicht in seiner Struktur
ähnlich, aber so im Detail.
Mal wird von dem einen Teilchen mehr erzeugt, mal weniger, mal vielleicht überhaupt
nicht. Auf einmal sind es ganz viele.
Und der eigentliche Wert entsteht dadurch, dass man eben sehr oft,
sehr lange das macht, alle Daten aufnimmt und sich es danach anschaut,
wie denn jetzt die tatsächliche Verteilung ist.
Weil wir im Prinzip ja generell immer nur alles über Wahrscheinlichkeiten überhaupt
erfassen können auf dieser Quantenebene, in der halt alles nicht klar bestimmt ist.
Da heißt es ja nicht, wenn das kommt, passiert das, sondern das passiert mit
einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Also es ist sehr klar bestimmt. Ich muss da widersprechen. Die Wahrscheinlichkeiten
sind sehr klar bestimmt. Also ich kann genau bestimmen, wie groß die Wahrscheinlichkeit
ist, nur das einzelne Event ist unbestimmt.
Das wollte ich damit zum Ausdruck bringen, ja.
Ja, das unterliegt einer Wahrscheinlichkeit. Aber auch in der Quantenmechanik
kann ich diese Wahrscheinlichkeiten sehr präzise ausrechnen.
Also genau, man kann dann die Wahrscheinlichkeiten ausrechnen,
aber man weiß halt nicht vor einer Kollision, was jetzt gerade dran ist.
Ganz genau.
Also das ist sozusagen das Unbestimmte, nur bestimmt wird es eben über die Beobachtung,
über die Zeit dadurch, dass ich sagen kann, okay, wir haben uns das jetzt irgendwie
angeschaut und diese Konstellation entsteht mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit und diese
Konstellation entsteht mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit und damit erforsche ich quasi
das Wesen dessen, was ich beobachte.
Okay, ich habe das halbwegs verstanden, glaube ich, hoffe ich.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Upgrades hat denn jetzt ALICE, das haben wir ja gerade gehört,
da wird immer wieder was ausgetauscht.
Wie sehr ähnelt denn ALICE nach seiner ursprünglichen Version?
Wie oft werden denn dort technische Änderungen vorgenommen?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Also schon vor 30 Jahren war schnell klar,
habe ich erzählt, dass man ein relativ schwaches, aber großvolumiges Magnetfeld
braucht. Das haben wir. Das haben wir sogar geerbt vom Vorgängerexperiment.
Da haben wir Kosten gespart. Und dass das zentrale, das Herzstück eine Zeitproduktionskammer
ist, das hat sich auch nicht geändert. Das ist im ersten Design drin.
Und dass man bei inneren Radien einen Silizium-Detektor hat,
auch das hat sich nicht geändert.
Und dann, das war sehr schnell klar, dass man den Doktor so bauen muss,
um das die Ziele zu erreichen, die man hat.
Dann das erste Upgrade war, der Myon-Arm kam später hinzu, das war aber,
das muss ich erzählen, 1993 hat dann sich eine sogenannte Proto-Kollaboration geformt.
Das waren also eine Reihe von Wissenschaftlern, die haben gesagt,
wir studieren das, wir untersuchen, welchen Detektor wir brauchen und kamen
dann sehr schnell mit diesem Konzept von einem solenoiden Magneten in der Zeitprojektionskammer
und einem inneren Siliziumdetektor und hat dann im Jahr 1993 einen Lettow-Intent vorgestellt,
also die Absicht, so einen Detektor zu bauen, um diese Physik des Quark-Clone-Plasmas
zu adressieren am Large Hadron Collider, in dem man das ausnutzt,
dass da auch Bleikerne beschleunigt werden können.
Und das wird begutachtet. Es gibt ein Komitee, das ist das LHC-Komitee,
LHCC, und das besteht aus Experten und die schauen sich an,
diese Vorschläge, die Gruppen machen, welche Direktoren gebaut werden sollen
und dieses Das Komitee berät direkt den Generaldirektor oder die Generaldirektoren am CERN.
Und die haben eben diesen Letter of Intent, den wir am 1.
März 1993 eingereicht haben, gesagt, okay, das finden wir gut,
macht weiter. Also wir haben eine positive Bewertung bekommen.
Und dann kam 1995 der Muonarm dazu.
Das waren eben Leute, die schon früher am CERN, am kleineren Beschleuniger,
am SPS, am Superproton-Synchrotron, Muon nachgewiesen haben,
eben genau um den Zerfall von Teilchen mit schweren Quarks.
Und die haben gesagt, wir machen da auch mit, wir bringen einen neuen Detektor
mit, wir wollen einen neuen Detektor bauen, die sind Myonarm.
Das war also das erste Upgrade sozusagen 1995, das war aber weit vor der ersten Konstruktion.
Dann kam, ich glaube, der erste, das ist fair zu sagen, der erste Upgrade-Detektor
war dieser Übergangsstrahlungsdetektor,
das ist ein Beitrag der deutschen Gemeinschaft und anderen Ländern,
Russland und Rumänien, die dann gesagt haben, okay, zwischen der Zeitprojektionskammer
und dem Flugzeitdetektor, da ist noch eine Lücke, radial, Und da bauen wir diesen
Übergangsstrahlungsdetektor ein, dass wir diese Elektronen und Positronen selektieren können.
Den haben wir 2008 eingebaut, also die ganze Konstruktion.
Das war noch mit der Konstruktion des ersten Detektors.
Und was wir jetzt gemacht haben, das war im Jahr 2019, 2021,
war eine lange Betriebspause des Large Hadron Colliders. Da wurde auch der Beschleuniger
konsolidiert, das heißt verbessert.
Dinge, die nicht so gut funktioniert haben, wurden verbessert.
Es wurden neue Instrumente eingebaut.
Das kann wahrscheinlich der Manfred Kramer dir besser erzählen.
Diese zweieinhalb Jahre haben wir genutzt, um unseren Detektor massiv zu erneuern.
Wir haben den gesamten Silicon Detektor komplett rausgenommen und haben jetzt
diesen hochgranularen Pixel-7-lagigen Pixeldetektor eingebaut.
Wir haben die Zeitprojektionskammer, die gesamte Auslöseelektronik erneuert,
was 90 Mannjahre an Arbeitsleistung ist.
Also wir haben praktisch auch diese Zeitprojektionskammer praktisch neu gebaut.
Da ist nur diese mechanische Struktur, die auch das elektrische Feld,
diese 100.000 Volt, zur Verfügung stellt, die ist geblieben und die gesamte Elektronik ist neu.
Und das ist eben geschuldet, dass es eine neue Technologie gibt für den Silizium-Detektor.
Das haben wir entwickelt in ALICE. Das ist der L-Pite Pixel-Chip.
Wir mussten die Elektronik verbessern, damit wir diese 50.000 Kollisionen pro
Sekunde mit der Zeitprojektionskammer instand halten können.
Es war nicht klar, ob das vor 10, 12 Jahren funktioniert. Das war wirklich eine
jahrelange Entwicklung von neuer Technologie. Da haben wir ein optimales Setup
gefunden, wie wir diese Auslöse bauen können. Und das funktioniert.
Wo wird denn diese Technik entwickelt?
In den Labors am CERN, also der Silizium-Detektor wurde ganz entscheidend hier
am CERN vorangetrieben.
Da gibt es eine Gruppe am CERN und unser vorheriger Spokesperson hat das entscheidend vorangetrieben.
Also wenn man Silizium-Technologie macht, das ist mit einem enormen Aufwand
verbunden. Da braucht man Reihenräume, da braucht man Maschinen.
Also das ist vom personellen und finanziellen Aufwand enorm und das CERN kann
das sehr gut machen. Das hat die richtige Größe.
In Deutschland braucht man dann schon die Nationallabors, zum Beispiel die Gesellschaft
für Schwerhörnforschung in Darmstadt, an der ich angestellt bin. Die können das machen.
Die Zeitprojektionskammer, das wurde federführend in Deutschland entwickelt,
auch von der GSI, von den Universitäten Frankfurt, Heidelberg.
Da braucht man Ingenieure, die nicht nur die Elektronik entwickeln,
sondern auch die Mechanik und so weiter und so fort. Und auch in Zusammenarbeit mit dem CERN.
Ich glaube das ist auch etwas, was bisher bei den Gesprächen noch gar nicht
so klar rausgekommen ist.
Man sieht ja hier das CERN so im Wesentlichen als Betriebsort.
Aber genau genommen wird ja alles erdacht. Also erstmal dieses,
was braucht man eigentlich, wie könnte das funktionieren, welche Technologien
benötigen wir denn dafür und dann müssen diese Technologien halt auch erdacht
und quasi erstmal erfunden werden.
Und dann ist die Frage, wie viel findet hier statt, wie viel findet woanders statt?
Also ist es der Normalfall, dass das alles woanders entwickelt wird und hier
wird nur überlegt, was braucht man? Oder findet hier auch konkret Technologiedevelopment statt?
Ja wie gesagt, diese Entwicklung von Siliziumdetektoren, das ist ja weltweit führend.
Viele, viele Gruppen benutzen jetzt diese Technologie, die wir in ALICE entwickelt
haben, in anderen Experimenten oder wollen die verwenden, auch für neue Maschinen in den USA.
Wir haben gerade jetzt, gerade in dem Moment, Gäste da aus den USA,
die eben genau unsere Silizium-Technologie verwenden wollen.
Also das wurde federführend am CERN gemacht, die Zeitproduktionskammer.
Da gibt es eine neue Technik, auch die wurde am CERN erfunden.
Das sind Gas-Elektron-Vervielfacherfolien, die heißen Gem-Gas-Elektron-Multipliers.
Und diese Technologie, da nimmt man eine sehr dünne Folie, bohrt Löcher rein
und isoliert die oben und unten und spitzt diese Löcher an. Und in diesen Löchern
entstehen sehr hohe Feldstärken.
Das ist das Geniale an so einer Gemfolie. Die wurde am CERN erfunden und die
haben uns diese riesigen Folien hergestellt.
Die haben Quadratmeter Größe und die haben wir dann benutzt,
um unsere Außerelektronik in Deutschland zu bauen. Also es wurde mit Gruppen
aus München, Darmstadt und Frankfurt gemacht.
Also nicht alles wird am CERN gemacht, aber vieles wird vorangeregtigt am CERN.
Okay. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was kommt bei raus?
Also was konnte denn mit Hilfe dieses Detektors und speziell eben dieser Bleikollisionen
und sozusagen der Betrachtung dieses Quark-Gluon-Plasmas herausgefunden werden über dieses Plasma?
Das ist ja so ein bisschen der Blick in die Zeit des Urknalls,
nicht unbedingt davor aber zumindest in dem Moment.
Welchen Erkenntnisgewinn konnte man bisher daraus ableiten, was hat sich daraus ergeben?
Also die erste Frage, was man sich stellt, wie hoch ist die Temperatur von dem
Ding, von dem Medium, das wir erzeugen?
Und die Temperatur kann man messen, indem man sich die Lichtteilchen anschaut, die Sonne.
Hat eine Temperatur in der Oberfläche von 6.000 Kelvin, 5.700 Grad Celsius.
Und wenn ich einfach das Spektrum des Lichts anschaue, das hier auf der Erde
ankommt, kann ich sofort auf die Temperatur der Oberfläche der Sonne schließen.
Salopp kann man sagen, man schaut sich das Spektrum, man schaut sich an,
wie viel kommt von der Farbe Grün an, wie viel kommt von der Farbe Rot an,
wie viel kommt von der Farbe Blau an.
Und dann habe ich, was die Physikern Plank-Spektrum nennen.
Das hat die meiste Farbe, die die Sonne ausstrahlt, ist tatsächlich grün und
dann kann ich sofort, das Planck Spektrum hat nur ein Parameter,
das ist die Temperatur, kann ich sofort die Temperatur bestimmen und so machen
wir das auch. Jetzt habe ich gesagt, die Sonne ist 6000 Kelvin heiß.
Unser Medium ist 2 Billionen Kelvin oder Grad Celsius heiß.
Das heißt, diese Wellenlänge verschiebt sich von dem optischen Spektrum,
das unsere Sonne aussendet, in die harte Röntgenstrahlung.
Also diese Photonen, die Lichtteilchen, die haben Milliarden von Elektronenvolt.
Unser optisches Licht hat einen Elektronenvolt etwa.
Und wenn man dieses Photon nachweist, also dieses Licht, das von der elektromagnetischen
Strahlung des Quarkplasmas kommt, dann kann man die Temperatur bestimmen.
Wir haben eine erste Messung, die ist noch nicht besonders genau.
Wie gesagt, diese Photonen und Elektronen, das sind ganz seltene Teilchen,
die muss ich da rauspicken auspicken, aus meinen zigtausend geladenen Teilchen
oder anderen Teilchen, die da entstehen.
Und dann gibt es noch andere Untergrundquellen, die auch Elektronen,
Positronen oder Photonen erzeugen. Also ich will sagen, das ist eine sehr schwierige
Messung, die sehr aufwendig ist, die sehr lange braucht, weil man sehr lange
Daten nehmen muss, um das Signal zu extrahieren.
Und da sehen wir, dass wir deutlich drüber sind über dieser Temperatur,
die es braucht, um so einen Quarkblumenplasma zu erzeugen.
In dem beobachteten Experiment.
Bei Alice.
Also man weiß deswegen, dass da eins ist. Ein Quark, Chlor und Plasma.
Das ist das, was einem die Gewissheit gibt?
Ja, also Gewissheit.
Das war wieder so ein schlimmes Wort benutzt.
Nein, das ist eine gute Frage. Was wir nicht haben ist eine Smoking Gun.
Eine Smoking Gun ist, wenn ich einen abschieße und dann raucht mein Colt noch,
dann weiß jeder, Der hat es getan.
Das gibt es halt bei uns nicht. Und das liegt daran, wir versuchen nicht ein
einzelnes Teilchen nachzuweisen, das zu rekonstruieren.
Wir haben ein System, das aus sehr, sehr vielen Teilchen besteht,
der sich sehr stark ausdehnt, dass der starken Wechselwirk unterliegt.
Und da habe ich kollektive Phänomene und es gibt nicht ein einziges Signal,
wo dann sofort alles klar ist, sondern man muss das beschreiben,
dass das konsistent ist. eine Temperatur, die weit drüber ist.
Auch bei den Hadronen können wir die Temperatur nachbestimmen.
Wenn ich jetzt das weiterdenke, wenn ich Hadronen messe, also Pion,
Proton, Kaon und so weiter, die sollte es ja nicht geben, wenn ich diese kritische
Temperatur überschreite.
Die sollten ja alle geschmolzen sein, weil ich da nur noch Quarks und Glon habe.
Und genau das beobachten wir. Aber irgendwann hat sich das System so weit ausgedehnt,
abgekühlt, dass wieder alles in normale Teilchen zerfällt.
Und wir beobachten auch bei den stark wechselwirkenden Teilchen,
dass die eben genau diese Grenztemperatur erreichen. Drüber könnten wir sie
nicht beobachten, weil sie nicht existieren.
Also die scheinen genau an der Phasengrenze, wo dieses Quark-Gluon-Plasma sich
so stark abgekühlt hat, dass es wieder in normale hadronische Materie zerfällt.
Und diese Hadronen, die wir beobachten, haben genau diese Grenztemperatur.
Dann sind es andere kollektive Effekte. Wir sehen, wie stark das Medium expandiert.
Was eine Entdeckung war, dass die schweren Quarks sehr viel Energie verlieren.
Ich habe also eine Farbladung, das ist alles starke Wechselwirkung.
Ich habe ein schweres Quark, ein Charmquark, das propagiert in diesem Medium
und das verliert sehr viel Energie.
Und das ist heute noch schwierig zu beschreiben für die Theorie,
warum so schwere Quarks so viel Energie verloren im Quark-Gluon-Plasma.
Das heißt alles was jetzt hier herausfällt ist quasi Nährboden für Wissenschaftlergruppen,
die am Quark-Gluon-Plasma an sich theoretisch und hier sozusagen auch praktisch forschen.
Ich denke, es ist fair zu sagen, dass unser Feld sehr stark experimentell getrieben
ist. Das heißt, es gibt neue Detektor-Technologien, die eben neue,
neuartige Messungen ermöglichen.
Und die Theorie versucht das zu
beschreiben und dann Erkenntnis über das Quark-Lungen-Plasma zu gewinnen.
Also das ist anders an der Teilchenphysik. Das Higgs-Boson wurde 48 Jahre vor
seiner Entdeckung vorhergesagt.
Die Schwierigkeit war, möglichst viel Energie zu haben, einen großen Kollider,
der auch dieses Teilchen erzeugen kann. Bei uns ist es, denke ich, eher umgekehrt.
Das ist das Experiment, das den Fortschritt vorantreibt.
Weil man jetzt einfach Daten bekommt aus etwas, was sich sonst nicht so ohne
weiteres theoretisch beschreiben lässt, weil man es noch gar nicht,
sein Wesen noch gar nicht verstanden hat.
Ja die Theorie ist eben schwierig. Ich habe versucht das mit der Schneefocke
zu erklären. Wenn ich ein Einzelsteilchen isoliert betrachte,
kann ich das sehr gut beschreiben theoretisch.
Ja, also das Quark-Klonen-Plasma ist ein Teil von ALICE. Wir können mit diesen
Kollisionen viel, viel mehr machen. Das tun wir auch. Das ist eine fantastische
Teilchenquelle, ein Quark-Klonen-Plasma.
Da kommen alle möglichen Teilchen raus, die es gibt. Die werden alle thermisch gekocht.
Die springen da alle raus. Wir können zum Beispiel auch nach Antimaterie schauen,
weil es wird genauso viel, die Energien sind so hoch beim Ladschadon-Kollider,
dass wir genauso viel Materie wie Antimaterie erzeugen.
Also es gibt aus den Kollisionen kommen genauso viel Proton raus wie Antiproton
und es gibt noch andere Teilchen.
Und zum Beispiel Anti-Alpha-Teilchen.
Rutherford hat ja damals das Alpha-Teilchen genommen. Das ist ein Heliumkern,
zwei Protonen, zwei Neutronen.
Und dazu gibt es auch ein Anti-Teilchen, das wurde schon entdeckt.
Das besteht aus zwei Antiprotonen, zwei Antineutronen.
Und jetzt können wir diese Teilchen untersuchen und schauen,
haben die genau die gleiche Masse, das Teilchen und das Antiteilchen.
Das ist eine fundamentale Vorhersage von jeder Theorie im Standardmodell der
Teilchenphysik, dass Teilchen und Antiteilchen gleich schwer sind und gleiche Lebensdauer haben.
Wenn das nicht so wäre, hätten wir eine große Krise in der theoretischen Physik.
Also niemand glaubt das.
Das heißt aber, wir müssen das testen. Und das können wir in ALICE,
wenn wir das testen mit den Daten, die wir jetzt die nächsten zehn Jahre nehmen.
Wir nehmen deutlich mehr Daten.
Wir haben jetzt letztes Jahr, im ersten Jahr schon in Proton-Proton-Kollisionen,
300 Mal mehr Daten aufgezeichnet, als wir die ganzen zehn Jahre davor aufgezeichnet haben.
Nur um so einen Geschmack dafür
zu kriegen, welche irren Datenraten unser Detektor jetzt verdauen kann.
Und da wollen wir zum Beispiel diese Teilchen-Antiteilchen-Symmetrie untersuchen
für Anti-Alpha-Teilchen.
Um diesen permanenten Test des Standardmodells durchzuführen.
Passt das Modell eigentlich wirklich so gut wie wir denken oder haben wir irgendwo nochmal einen Flaw?
Aber ist schon irgendwas damit bestätigt worden oder ist es sozusagen,
es konnte nur bisher nicht widerlegt werden? Wie muss man das so definieren?
Niemand erwartet ernsthaft, dass wir jetzt einen Unterschied sehen,
aber man soll, Steven Weinberg hat das mal gesagt, den ich sehr verehre,
der leider letztes Jahr gestorben ist, ein großer theoretischer Physiker,
schauen, wo niemand vorher geschaut hat. Das können wir auch,
diese Möglichkeit haben wir in ALICE.
Wir haben zum Beispiel das schon gemacht für Deuteron und Helium-3-Kerne.
Da haben wir die Teile, ein Deuteron ist ein Proton und ein Neutron und Helium-3
ist zwei Antiprotonen und nur ein Antineutron.
Da haben wir schon gezeigt, dass wir Massendifferenzen messen können.
Mit guter Genauigkeit haben wir das veröffentlicht. Und der nächste Schritt
ist einfach mit mehr Daten können wir dann zu schwereren Kernen gehen.
Also es ist noch nichts, wir haben noch nichts gefunden, das dem Standardmodell widerspricht.
Du hättest das in der Zeitung schon oder im Fernsehen gesehen.
Mit Sicherheit. Aber was ist denn schon an Erkenntnissen herausgekommen,
wovon ich auch noch nichts mitbekommen habe? Was sind so die grundlegenden Erkenntnisse,
die Alice abgeworfen hat?
Zum Beispiel die Teilchen haben eine bestimmte Lebensdauer und wir können,
weil unser Detektor so präzise ist, zum ersten Mal werden ja alle möglichen
Teilchen erzeugt bei uns in dieser Bleiblei-Kollision.
Wir können dann Teilchen mit sehr hoher Genauigkeit, deren Masse oder Lebensdauer
auch messen. Wir haben jetzt gerade das Lambda-Baryon untersucht.
Das ist ein Neutron, wo ich ein leichtes Quark rausnehme und dafür ein bisschen
schwereres, das Strange-Quark, reintue.
Und diese Lebensdauer hat eine bestimmte experimentelle Präzision und wir haben
das um einen Faktor 3 verbessert.
Also man weiß jetzt auch dreimal mehr, welche Lebensdauer dieses Lambda Teilchen hat.
Das kann man jetzt in einen Kernverband einbauen, in einen Deuteron zum Beispiel.
Und da gab es 50 Jahre lang Spekulationen, ob das, wenn das jetzt dieses Lambda
Baryon gebunden ist, also ein Neutron mit einem schweren Quark,
einem Strange Quark, ob das dann die Lebensdauer beeinflusst.
Und da gab es die letzten 50 Jahre viele, viele Experimente,
die was gesehen haben, die keinen Unterschied gesehen haben und das haben wir
jetzt auch entscheidend beantwortet, die Frage.
Dieses Lebensdauer ist die gleiche im Kernverbund von einem Deuteron wie für
ein Freies Lambda-Teilchen.
Also es sind einfach Präzisionsmessungen, die gehen dann auch in die Bibel der
Teilchenphysik ein, weil alle Teilchen, die man kennt, sind gelistet in einem Particle Data Book.
Das wird jedes Jahr auf den neuesten Stand gebracht und da haben wir als eine
Messung beigetragen, die dreimal genauer ist als alle anderen Experimente zuvor.
Was sind denn jetzt, also das ist natürlich für die Wissenschaft super spannend,
solche Detailupdates und so ein permanentes Verbessern eines Verzeichnisses
aller wesentlichen Eigenschaften.
Was sind so die großen Fragen, die durch die Arbeit mit Alice touchiert werden?
Ja, das ist die zugrundelegende Theorie, das ist eine relativistische Quantenfeldtheorie,
die die starke Wechselwirkung beschreibt. Die so beschreibt,
wie Quarks und Gluten miteinander, sich zueinander verhalten,
wie die wechselwirken, das ist die Quanten-Chromodynamik.
Es gibt die Quanten-Elektrodynamik, die beschreibt eben die elektromagnetische
Wechselwirkung auf dem Quantenniveau und ist relativistisch korrekt.
Und so gibt es in der starken Wechselwirkung die Quanten-Chromodynamik.
Da kommt das auch mit der Farbe her, wir haben ja vorhin schon darüber gesprochen,
das ist natürlich nicht so, dass wir hier von Farben reden, sondern das ist
ein Bild, um einfach Zusammenhänge dieser Teilchen, also der Wechselwirkung
zu beschreiben, also Eigenschaften davon zu beschreiben.
Und wahrscheinlich weil mal wieder nichts anderes im Regal zu greifen war,
hat man gesagt, dann nehmen wir jetzt einfach Farben und deswegen heißt es auch Chromo.
Ganz genau. Also es ist streng genommen die Farbladung, genau wie die elektrische
Ladung die Ursache der elektromagnetischen Kraft ist, so ist die Farbladung
die Ursache der Farbladung.
Ja, man hätte jetzt auch ein anderes Bild nehmen können als Farbe,
aber das ist es einfach geworden.
Ja, aber das weißt du wahrscheinlich, das kommt daher, weil die Quarks in drei,
um einen Proton zu machen brauche ich drei Quarks, um einen Neutron zu machen
brauche ich drei Quarks.
Da hat man gesagt, also zwei Quarks geht nicht. Es geht ein Quark und ein Antiquark,
das heißt diese Farbladung, das Quark hat Rot, Gelb oder Grün,
die kann man auch 1, 2, 3 nennen oder wie auch immer, dass die drei Farben im
Proton, die drei verschiedenen Farben im Proton,
Farben, die ein Proton haben kann, müssen sich so addieren, dass es farbneutral ist.
Also rot, grün, blau.
Rot, grün, blau, aber eigentlich nach der Farbenlehre ist es nicht rot,
grün, blau, sondern rot, gelb, blau oder umgekehrt. Auf jeden Fall hat man das,
genau wie du sagst, versucht anschaulich zu machen. Warum habe ich jetzt drei
und nicht zwei oder sieben?
Und das kann man mit den Spektralfarben sehr gut erklären, dass dann immer eine weiße Farbe rauskommt.
Ok, aber das ist sozusagen, man will die starke Kernkraft besser verstehen,
man weiß die kommen einfach in Dreiergruppen, also muss es dann irgendeiner
Form Eigenschaften geben, die dafür sorgen, dass es immer drei sein müssen.
Und was wir gut verstehen theoretisch, also nicht ich, sondern meine Freunde
aus der Theorie, ist eben, wenn man isolierte Prozesse bei sehr hohen Energien
anschaut, dann kann man das sehr genau berechnen.
Wir machen eine störungstheoretische Rechnung und kann die Experimente beschreiben.
Was wir in ALICE machen, ist, wir gucken uns die Vielteilchenaspekte an.
Also nicht ein isoliertes Teilchen, ein isoliertes Quark, sondern sehr,
sehr viele Teilchen. Sehr viele Quarks und Gluren in verschiedenen Farben,
schwere Quarks, leichte Quarks.
Und wir versuchen die Vielteilchenaspekte der starken Wechselwirkung zu untersuchen
und experimentell präzise zu bestimmen.
Und das ist, was wir noch sehr wenig verstehen, obwohl es da sehr großen Aufwand
gibt in der Theorie. Es ist also noch ein recht junges Feld,
da kommen wir zurück zu der Schneeflocke.
Ich kann die Quantenelektrodynamik nehmen, ich kann damit aber nicht ausrechnen,
welche Form eine Schneeflocke hat, weil sehr sehr viele Teilchen daran teilnehmen
und dann gibt es auch neue Effekte, die man erst mal so nicht in den elementaren Gleichungen sieht.
Und gibt's hier auch eine Perspektive so die die großen Fragezeichen der Physik
in irgendeiner Form zu bespielen,
das was so auch die Kosmologie vor allem irre macht mit dunkler Materie und dunkler Energie,
also ich meine wenn wir hier mit diesem Quark-Luhren-Plasma sozusagen an der,
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Geburt sagen soll,
aber zumindest an diesem Urknall, diesem sehr besonderen Moment,
wenn wir da sozusagen in dieser Ursuppe herumforschen, lässt sich daraus irgendetwas
ableiten für das, was wir heute im All sehen und uns noch nicht erklären können.
Ja, alles kann was dazu beitragen und hat beigetragen zur dunklen Materie.
Dunkle Materie ist dunkel, das heißt wir sehen sie nicht, die strahlt nicht
elektromagnetisch, die sendet kein Licht aus.
Und wir wissen nur von ihrer Existenz, weil wir sehen wie die sich gravitativ
verhält. Also die beeinflusst andere Objekte um sich herum.
Die Menschen sind nur Materie, obwohl wir ja auch nicht sicher sind, ob es welche ist.
Also es ist nicht Energie, es ist nicht nur Energie, es ist auch Materie.
Aber gut eigentlich wissen wir gar nichts was dunkle Materie ist.
Es tut das, was normalerweise nur Materie tut. Man sieht sie nicht deswegen
nennt man sie dunkle Materie, aber es könnte sich ja auch herausstellen,
dass es was komplett anderes ist, was die Gravitation mit beeinflusst.
Ja, also wenn du mich fragst, das ist aber meine persönliche Meinung,
dunkle Materie ist eine Umschreibung für unsere komplette Unkenntnis, für was das ist.
Ich glaube das ist ganz okay. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die versuchen die Gleichung
der Gravitation so zu ändern, dass man gar keinen neuen Materieterm findet,
aber das hat eigene Probleme.
Also, das Standardmodell der Teilchenphysik, das hat was dazu zu sagen,
nicht das Standardmodell, sondern die erste, die minimale supersymmetrische Erweiterung.
Das heißt, das hat man ja bevor der LHC angeschaltet wurde, gab es ja große
Hoffnung, dass die sogenannte Supersymmetrie verwirklicht ist in der Natur.
Das heißt, es gibt also eine Theorie, die sagt, okay, für alle Teilchen,
die wir jetzt im Standardmodell haben, gibt es ein korrespondierendes supersymmetrisches
Teilchen, das viel schwerer ist. Zum Beispiel gibt es zum Elektron ein s-Elektron.
Oder zum Neutrino gibt es ein Neutralino. Also man verdoppelt den Teilchen so,
der Elementarteilchen.
Die müssen viel schwerer sein, sonst hätten wir sie schon gesehen.
Und das war die große Hoffnung, als der Large Hadron Collider losging.
Bisher hat man noch keine gesehen.
Und ich glaube die Hoffnung ist ein bisschen am schwinden.
Deshalb gucken wir trotzdem danach. Und was wir gemacht haben in ALICE ist,
wir können dazu einen wichtigen Beitrag liefern.
Zum Beispiel das Experiment EMS, das Alpha Magnet Spektrometer,
das auf der internationalen Raumstation Daten nimmt.
Das guckt zum Beispiel nach Anti-Kernen, zum Beispiel nach Anti-Helium-3-Kernen.
Zwei Antiprotonen, ein Antineutron. Und dann ist die Frage, die haben noch keinen,
zumindest nicht veröffentlicht, nachgewiesen.
Wenn die jetzt Anti-Helium-3 sehen, also ein Anti-Kern, recht schwerer,
schwerer als das Proton zum Beispiel. Immer noch ein leichter Kern, okay.
Dann ist die Frage, wo kommt das her? Und das könnte zum Beispiel von Prozessen
kommen, von einem supersymmetrischen Teilchen, dem Neutralino.
Das Neutralino ist elektrisch neutral, nimmt also nicht an der elektromagnetischen Wechselwirkung teil.
Es ist das leichteste supersymmetrische Teilchen. Das heißt,
alle anderen Teilchen müssen irgendwann in Richtung dieses Neutralinos zerfallen sein.
Die wurden am Urknall entdeckt, erzeugt und das Neutralino ist stabil.
Das heißt, es kann auch nicht in Standardmodellteilchen zerfallen.
Das heißt, wenn es die wirklich gibt und das ist der Ansatz dunkler Materie
mit der Teilchenphysik zu erklären, Dann wurden die möglicherweise beim Urknall
erzeugt und bevölkern zum Beispiel den Balg unserer Galaxie.
Und es stellt sich heraus, die Neutralinos sind auch ihr eigenes Antiteilchen.
Das heißt, die zerfallen zwar nicht, wenn ich aber viele Neutralinos habe,
kannst du mir noch folgen, dann können die sich miteinander vernichten und würden
auch schwere Antikerne erzeugen.
Das heißt also ein Antihelium-3-Kern im Weltall wäre ein Signal für die Vernichtung
von zwei supersymmetrischen Teilchen, die Kandidaten für dunkle Materie sind.
Und wir haben bestimmt, wenn dieses Teilchen irgendwo weit weg von uns in der
Galaxie erzeugt wird, ob das überhaupt bei der Internationalen Space Station ankommen würde.
Also wir haben mit diesen Antihelium-3-Kernen, die aus unserem Quark-Lum-Plasma
kommen, haben wir bestimmt, wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist,
dass so ein Teilchen absorbiert wird auf seinem Weg vom Balg der Galaxie bis
zur Internationalen Space Station.
Wir haben festgestellt, dass unsere Galaxie recht transparent ist dafür.
Also drei Viertel aller Antihelium-Dreikerne kommen noch an, wenn es die gibt.
Wenn es die gibt, also wenn AMS das sieht, wäre das ein wunderbares Signal.
Ich habe zu AMS auch schon eine Raumzeitfolge gemacht, Nummer 38,
das ist jetzt schon eine Weile her. Also das Ding ist jetzt schon seit ein paar
Jahren in Betrieb. Ist denn da überhaupt schon was Interessantes bei herausgekommen,
was sich mit der Arbeit von Ellis kombinieren lässt?
Ja, die haben genau diese Teichensprecken gemessen und es zeigt sich,
die Protonen sind, es gibt ja auch kosmische Strahlung, die auf unsere Atmosphäre
trifft, da kommen auch Antiprotonen raus.
Das heißt die Antiprotonen und die bisschen schwereren Antideuterungen, die sind wohl nicht gut.
Der Untergrund, auch diese Prozesse haben wir gemessen, die kosmische Strahlung
trifft ja auf ruhende Kerne in unserer Atmosphäre und die Energie am LHC ist ein Kollider.
Das heißt, was wir am LHC haben, trifft zufällig genau die Energie,
die die kosmische Strahlung im Schwerpunktsystem macht.
Und da haben wir auch Produktionsraten von Antiproton, Antideuteron,
also von Antikernen gemessen, was dann der Untergrund für solche Messungen ist.
Also es gibt einen Untergrund und es gibt ein Signal von der Neutralino-Vernichtungsstrahlung.
Und daraus schließen wir das mit Antihelium 3, wenn man ein gutes Signal extrahieren
kann, wenn es das eins gibt.
Das heißt es gibt da noch keine Smoking Gun für die dunkle Materie,
das ist alles noch Theorie?
Ja natürlich, sonst hättest du davon gehört.
Es gibt aber auch andere Ansätze für dunkle Materie, schwarze Löcher,
mini schwarze Löcher, die überall sind im Universum. Also das ist sehr sehr
aktuell natürlich momentan.
Ja man ist sich auf jeden Fall nicht einig. Bin sehr gespannt ob da demnächst nochmal was kommt.
Das zeigt ja, dass es spannend ist.
Ich habe noch so eine Erinnerung, dass auch die Theorien, die hinter Neutronensternen
stehen, mit diesem Quark, Gluon, Plasma zu tun haben.
Ja, die Frage ist, als man nur Protonen und Neutronen kannte,
da haben die Herren Oppenheimer und Volkow schon in den 1930er Jahren gezeigt,
Man nimmt einfach die Kernmaterie, die Eigenschaften, wie stark lässt sich Kernmaterie komprimieren.
Und irgendwann, die Kernmaterie zieht sich natürlich an, aber irgendwann stoßen
die zusammen und dann kann man die nicht weiter komprimieren.
Und das ist das, was einen Neutronenstern stabilisiert gegen den gravitativen
Kollaps. Also der Neutronenstern hat ja 1,5 Sonnenmassen oder so,
also im Bereich der Sonnenmasse.
Und wenn die Kernfusion beendet ist, gibt es keinen thermodynamischen Druck,
der diesen gravitativen Kollaps auffällt.
Das heißt, der Stern fällt in sich zusammen, aber die Kernmaterie stabilisiert,
die Inkompressibilität der Kernmaterie stabilisiert diesen Neutronenstern.
Und die Herren Oppenheimer, Volkow und Tolman, denke ich, die haben einfach
sich die Struktur der Kernmaterie hergenommen und gesagt, Okay,
maximal kann ich mit gewöhnlicher Kernmaterie Neutronensternen bis 1,8 Sonnenmassen stabilisieren.
Wenn der schwerer ist, kollabiert der und wird zum schwarzen Loch.
Jetzt hat man vor zehn Jahren gefunden, es gibt Neutronensterne,
die haben ein bisschen mehr Masse.
Und die Frage ist, was verhindert, dass diese Neutronensterne in sich zusammenstürzen
und ein schwarzes Loch binden? Was stabilisiert die gegen den Kollaps?
Und das können nicht nur Neutronen und die Neutronen sein.
Das kann ein Quarkblumenlastmal sein oder nur die Quarks, dass man eben keine
Neutronen hat, sondern so eine Quarksuppe im inneren Kern von den Neutronen
schneiden. Ist aber alles spekulativ.
Alles noch Spekulation.
Ja, jetzt könnte ich fragen, haben wir noch was vergessen? Haben wir unter Garantie.
Es gibt ja viele Details.
Was sollten wir vielleicht noch am Ende hinzufügen zu dem, was wir bisher besprochen haben?
Das Bild abzurunden, was man von diesem Detektor, diesem Experiment hat.
Also ALICE gibt es jetzt seit 30 Jahren. Wir haben im letzten Monat den 30-jährigen Geburtstag gefeiert.
Wir haben jetzt einen brandneuen Detektor, mit dem wir 10 Jahre messen.
Und danach wollen wir einen komplett... Da geht auch die Zeitprojektionskammer
raus, weil die Raten dann so hoch werden am LHC, dass wir die Zeitprojektionskammer
nicht nutzen können. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir einen Durchbruch in der
Detektortechnologie mit Silizium.
Wir wollen in zehn Jahren einen komplett siliziumbasierten Detektor bauen,
der praktisch gar keine Masse hat, dass die Teilchen überhaupt nicht stören.
Das wollen wir in zehn Jahren einbauen und zehn Jahre damit messen bis 2042.
Also jetzt ist ALICE 30 und wir haben einen konkreten Plan für die nächsten
zehn Jahre und wollen noch 20 Jahre weitermachen bis zum Ende des LACs.
Das heißt, dieses Upgrade mit den Pixeldetektoren aus Siliziumfolien,
das ist im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen die Zukunft dieses Detektors.
Also es hat sich als so gut erwiesen, dass man davon möglichst viel haben möchte.
Ja, ganz genau. Und andere Detektoren haben auch Silizium, aber was besonders
ist an unserem, dass der so unglaublich dünn ist und wir entfernen wirklich
alles. Auch die Ausleseelektronik ist momentan im jetzigen installierten Detektor
noch auf dem Silizium aufgebracht.
Wir entfernen alles, was nicht aktiver Sensor ist und haben damit praktisch
einen masselosen Detektor. Ich glaube, das ist ein einzigartiger Detektor in der Welt.
Super Kai, vielen Dank an dieser Stelle für diese Ausführung.
Schwierig irgendwie so eine hochkomplexe Technologie,
die sich in so einem super Spezialbereich der Physik und damit der Wissenschaft
bewegt, irgendwie zu vermitteln, aber ich bin schon wieder schlauer geworden.
Insofern vielen Dank nochmal für die Ausführung und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören
hier bei Raumzeit. Das war der LS Detektor.
Weitere Detektoren werden folgen bis wir hier das CERN ausreichend zusammengefasst haben.
Bis dahin sage ich Tschüss, bis bald!